[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
round one of the London chest classic
started with explosive action but
peaceful results in the all-american
matchup between Hikaru Nakamura and
Fabiana Khurana it was the recent world
championship challenges that went out
guns blazing Khurana threw everything he
had against his opponents king and
Nakamura was against the ropes he found
ways to hold on and escaped by the skin
of his teeth Levon Aronian proved yet
again his expertise in the Spanish as
they put tremendous pressure in Maxima
sheer legrasse position
the Frenchman resourcefully sacrificed
an exchange and thanks to inaccuracies
by his opponent the game's simplified
into a draw the players reverse color
and try to flip the script as they to
classical chest coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to day two of the London chest
classic we are here with the final four
players of the grand chester after a
thrilling season they two means two more
classical chests behind us the
wellington arch commemorating Great
Britain's victories in the Napoleonic
Wars let's see what kind of battles the
players bring to us today as we take
this action back to our studio in st.
Louis Thank You alejandro and here
receive Fabiano carolina back babies
chillin before round 2 actually I think
I'm talking to former manager
international master Lauren's friend
always a crowd favorite and of course PC
Mac seen my share look Rob as well I'm
Jennifer jihadi I'm here with
Grandmaster gassers heroine to call
round 2 of the grand chess Tour Finals
London chess class a always good to be
with you Jennifer hello everybody
welcome to our coverage of these finals
of the Grantchester we're using a
different format this year elimination
matches Jennifer and the first day was
really really good games oh yeah it was
actually thrilling when you only only
have two classical games are always a
little bit concerned what's gonna happen
right are they gonna fizzle out but no
way I mean Fabiano Carolina really kept
us on the edge of our seats yesterday as
he also did in London I had the World
Championship so we're used to seeing
this guy in an exciting battle that said
both games were drawn the game between
Bobby and naka and also the game between
MDL and Livan exactly well let's take a
look at our current scores well yes if
we look at our current scores you see
that we have three points each that's
because there's six points at stake in
each classical game so I'm so far
everybody has grabbed three from round
one note that you're going to need 15
out of 28 total points to move on to the
finals here at the London test perfect
and the runners-up will pay for
Grantchester positions 3 & 4 here we see
our tournament schedule we are in the
classic again two out of the two classic
games and then tomorrow we move to rapid
and blitz no don't be fooled by that
parenthetical playoffs we play rapid
inputs no matter what it's it's just
that at the end of the rapid in blitz
the scores are tied then we do go to
playoffs exactly and we do it all again
for the finals well we start with
classical chess games and those were six
points each then we moved to rapid two
teams rapid each rapid games worth four
points and the blitz games are worth two
that's how you get the 28 points total
and that's why you need the 15 to win
the match what a marvelous shot Yuri as
very confident and calm he actually came
to the hall early it looks like be
released if any of the players recently
having celebrating his 31st birthday
Nakamura seems to be a calmer version
but just as good as calculating as we
saw yesterday and we've got with us
Grandmaster Christian karela who's gonna
give us his thoughts on today's matches
thanks guys and welcome back everybody
to day two of the final leg of the 2018
Grantchester the lan and chess classic
despite the peaceful results yesterday
we've seen some explosive games and the
matches are heating up let's look at the
head-to-head going into this event from
the Grantchester
between Cara Juana and Nakamura we see
everything is very very close very tight
in the classical Fabiano is leading one
to zero in the rapid everything is tied
but in the blitz Nakamura overwhelms
Fabiano for victories to Fabiano's - in
the other match the match between the
Frenchman with three names nvl and the
superstar of armenia Leveroni on
everything is tied what is it going to
take to separate this man we see in
blitz three and three to three in rapid
one I have two one and a half in the
classical a draw who was going to take
to set
this - only time will tell let's go to
London and hear what Alejandro has to
say about all of this
Thank You Christian we're here at Google
headquarters centre of London and what a
spectacular venue it is you can breathe
the chest culture in the building we
have of course the players in the London
chest classic well they're very strong
but there are so many grandmasters here
we have the British knockout
championship we have the live
commentators a lot of the seconds we
have former feeder world champion Rustom
cousin john up in the house we have a
team back row and let's not forget this
is the house of arguably the strongest
engine in the world currently alpha zero
is being developed here this is arguably
the best place to play chess here in
London let's see if the tie is broken
today as we happy Cara Nakamura with the
white pieces he had a tough day
yesterday but he survived I love what I
wrote here and who put them pressure
also with the white pieces what do you
think guys do you think the tie is gonna
be broken today or are we heading equal
in to the rapid in blitz
we'll see Alejandra certainly soak up
that atmosphere get that chest spirit
going that alpha0 going but Jenn these
matches big prize money up for grabs
that's right a lot of stocking stuffers
we've got a hundred twenty a for first
and a total price under $300,000 notice
that differentiation for surf before
because they are gonna be playing a
third place match exactly just that
swing between become making the finals
and not there's a lot at stake guys
because exactly your expected value in
the final is a hundred case right
exactly so good reasons to win the match
and you got to wonder what the strategy
will be today of course I think the
players that the black pieces will have
no problems going into the playoffs
especially Maxine Basha orlag Rob
knowing that he's playing black today
and he's such a strong blitz buyer
exactly or blitz games at stake he's
happy to go into the playoffs Nakamura
feels the same way the difference there
is that Nakamura is the one with the
white pieces exactly and again two
stories the first of course is this man
Fabiano has a chance of becoming the
number one rated player in the world in
classical chess should he win he would
overtake Magnus Carlsen and then of
course in the blitz you have nvl who's
also number two in the blitz rating just
behind Magnus Carlsen
so MVL will be looking to score very
well in the Blitz and fabbi of course is
looking to score very well in the
classic but he'll have black today and
want to get gen get the Christian to
jump in here Christian what is what is
he Carlo doing these days with the white
pieces well I think his burying his
openings generally I think he opens up
with one c4 he also tried one before a
few times one e4 of course is one of his
main weapons he's trying to kind of
surprise his opponents in the opening
and his second crease Little John is
doing a fantastic job with the computers
and he's giving him he's feeding
he car a lot of interesting ideas an
interesting novelty so we're going to
have to wait and see what he has against
Fabiano but what is his strategy going
into this game is he looking for a
mellow game in which potentially he
could press for a for a long time but
without much risk is he looking to take
more risk than necessary I don't think
so I think he's going to try to look for
calm waters and and just try to take
Fabiana to go through the rapid and
British divers all right and then Levon
Aronian
I would have said a year ago Levon was
more of a c4 Queen's pawn opening player
but Levon Jennifer he's become one
afford let's go that's right and the
thing filled copy plays that's home so
many interesting games including one
against MDL right right but will we see
an open Sicilian night or if we know MVR
is a stubborn is a sitting duck in d4
he's a sitting duck in e4 he plays the
groom further against d4 he prayed he
plays the neither of
efore and he doesn't do anything else
right and this really helps him in the
blitz and rapid time controls because he
knows these positions by heart in the
classical though you have a lot
especially Aronian going into this match
he had a lot of time to prepare new
ideas in both the groom felt and the
neither so I wouldn't be surprised if
we're going to c104 one day for today
and then if they once they go into the
rapid and blitz section huronian is
going to start to look try other ideas
in new openings okay so I'm predicting
1.e4 for the LaVon game but in the
Nakamura game no prediction for ya
you're gonna go English now of course in
the World Chess Championship match 1 c4
was played twice by Magnus and E 5 was
fabiana's response but it was only in
the rapid the tiebreaker that Magnus
scored with one c4 no absolutely and you
know Fabiano is quite stubborn himself
he shows his openings and and he trusts
them he has he brings new ideas to the
game all the time but generally at the
later stage of the game so we're going
to have to wait and see where our
Nakamura is going to try to target
Fabiano but nevertheless I think Fabiana
will not have a lot of difficulty
getting out of the opening with all the
preparation he has behind him I don't
think this is going to be a difficult
task for him to equalize I was trying to
recall that game between Levon and
Maxine it was so interesting and it was
not in the same field Cup it was in the
same room it in blitz that was that wild
night or for our Maxime had a great
position and then Levon ended up winning
remember that no ok well maybe a
Christian can bring it up later
oh yeah that's nice ok that was a fun
game but you're right that was the rapid
and blitz not the same Cup so these
gentlemen are also very very close
friends
MBL and LaVon always makes it a little
bit awkward I always had difficulty in
my chest career playing against somebody
I was really close with about you Jen
why do you how did you deal with
friendship issues oh but first we've got
my mouth um oh the semi-finals of the
Grunch estatal finals I'm Malcolm Payne
the chief executive of chess in schools
and communities the UK charity that
delivers Chester 25,000 state school
children around the UK and we organize
the London chess classic we're very
proud that this is the 10th edition and
it's already proving to be one of the
best we're very thankful to deepmind for
giving us this incredible venue it's
been nice to talk to some spectators
here just before the games if coming
here for the first time and just amazed
that the wonderful playing conditions
and surroundings that we're lucky enough
to be able to play in now it's a
tradition of the London chess classic
that will always like one of the
children who are in the program to make
the ceremonial first move and earlier
this morning the three schools who are
here for schools activities played a
match against some children from the
Parisian suburb of and yeah using a
video link and some chess con software
and I'm pleased to say that the children
in London 1 to nil and yep there we are
hands in the air
[Applause]
and I particularly liked the amount of
noise that we made on the second game
when we counted down the French team as
they lost on time from 10 seconds down
to 1 and then an enormous cheer at the
end of the game yeah it could have been
football so I'd like you to welcome to
make the ceremonial first move one of
the players who is making making a lot
of very very good suggestions including
one extremely nice move that one
appalled and set us on our way in the
first game so please welcome from
Goodwin school Alex Quinn it oh excuse
me Garrett
excuse me Ali's Derek thank you
so with Alex come up so you're gonna
make the first move for Hikaru and we've
already seen what a good player you are
so what move would you like to play make
sure it's a good one okay you could make
it you make it alright shake hands with
the car route alright that's it hey Cory
pretty good move alright we'll see if he
keeps it
alright very well done then Alex thanks
a lot and yeah you must come back again
next time we have to play Paris all
right let's get the games going and
there we have it Jennifer
184 good move but should he Karl play
1.e4 then we could expect the Petrov and
let's see as the clock been started oh I
think he's keeping it it's keeping me
for it no yes
think about it psychologically if you
wanted to play d4 c4 he wouldn't keep
the pond there exactly because it could
create some confusion 365 no like I said
we would expect them Petrov after Knight
f3 he could play the bishops opening
Bishop c4 to try to dodge the truck but
no right into it okay well we'll see if
he carro can do something that Magnus T
Magnus could not which is
pierce the petrov that would be
something
if you could have to give it to him if
he manages to it to find something to
get an advantage well we'll certainly
keep a very close eye on that game and
then of course let's just take a look at
the Levon Aronian game the one game that
I really expected efore in Levon
actually started with Knight f3 and it's
a hybrid it's a that's the thing Levon
is so good that this at various move
orders right all the time right comes up
with something new and confuses you and
then it's very difficult to find those
over the board find the best moves all
over the board right and it seems
they're going into this old line that's
right you probably are an expert on this
are you yeah actually I played a lot a
lot of games with us in the old days
Bishop e6 as well as 93 check with the
two favorite moves Knight three checked
so now there's the option of equality
after a night the four king of 493 and
then you can repeat as as well right but
of course against 93 you righteous play
Queen te2 here after Knight f4 check
King f1 Bishop e6 was the ocean six
Bishop e6 that's what they used to do
then I had a game after Bishop e6 again
this was the old 3rd ooh maybe psychosis
okay that's very different than what I'm
used to uh-huh Black has moved his
knight how many times in game 6 of the
world exactly no one's gonna beat that
record no I was gonna say that this was
the old lying Bishop e6 as played
numerous times in my career and then we
would take take and I had introduced
this pawn sacrifice idea with b4 against
Adam Kolakowski a grandmaster from
Poland but 96 was MBL's choice and hmm
ok that that's moving again this night
we went to f6 to d5 to be for 2 D 3 to
f4 and we do have a pawn sacrifice on
the board you play the move D for D for
D for whoa you want to try to take
advantage of your edge in before it
turned against Maxine yesterday of it
well we're now it cuz it was a similar
principle with Maxine when you played
before yesterday right which was later
crippled with because he get ended up
getting a worse position yes it was such
a natural mode like but here very early
in the game similarly we're trying to
take advantage of box development and I
love the move when I see it right now
yeah but now you've got to justify well
I mean all the blacks pieces are on the
first rank but now you've got to justify
what's the follow-up ok so I take it now
you could potentially if you were really
worried about your material you could
play Bishop takes c6 and they takes the
bishop is so sweet but you wanted to
play Knight d5 yeah yeah if you're gonna
sack up on play it as if you know it's
what you want to do knight c6 do we want
to play d4 like I did with Adam collect
off-screen I love the idea I mean
they're also that notice that bishop on
c1 doesn't have any other obvious
squares that foreign g5 are taken up
right well f4 and g5 you're right we
could play because I'm not sure I would
take it yeah but okay even if you were
to play Bishop g5 and I'd ask you oh
what's your intention yeah like okay if
I play like a groom Feld and they I mean
right now I've got this pawn mm-hmm
pretty firmly defended some before I
like better that's right yeah yeah I do
too because the idea is that after let's
say a six bishop here your your
intentions are clear you want to play a
form b5 and you know why don't win this
pawn back well let's move along because
we'll probably play g6 Bishop g7 which
helps us also to castle
now g6 and Bishop g7 right away also
maybe I just wanted to turn into
Christian for a second and actually
Christian is this all theory I will have
to check that database because my
database is not working very well right
now okay but I'm sure this has been
played if not LaVon definitely has seen
this because in his preparation and this
is exactly what I was mentioning
yesterday we're going to see some very
interesting ideas because he had so much
time to prepare for this match since
August he knows that he's going to play
against Maxime and to make comparison
with the World Championship match we've
seen black dictate where the game is
going generally in this instance white
is the dictating where he wants to take
the game right and I think this is going
to definitely give him a very good
chance as at scoring today all right
very good
and turning to the game between Ricardo
and Fabiano the players are following i
don't know precisely which game number
but this was all played in the World
Championship match in London and this is
the 97 and d5 line of play and this
looks like it's all been seen before
theory up to this position after Bishop
d3 in the first thing that goes through
my mind when I see this move Bishop d3
on the board as I start to think well
are you going to play Bishop takes h7
and 9 g5 shag I'm going to be afraid of
that happening so I start to think
should I try to go and eliminate this
Bishop Bishop c5 is played actually
Bishop c5 was already done by Bishop d4
quickly by Hikaru okay so both players
showing that they're very well prepared
because they've just been zipping right
along here and now again I'm looking at
these two bishops eyeballing
well I want to say potential sacrifices
Bishop takes h7 check 95 check Bishop
takes g7 these types of things and black
should not be just sitting waiting for
white to execute it's okay it takes
before I played now you should taste
this move looks like okay well White's
gonna get some kind of small advantage
because we have the better Bishop and
now you've gotten rid of your dark
squared bishop to the bishop o'linn c8
doesn't have a home yet but okay at the
same time how big is it yeah is like if
I just play night at six here notice
that I'm looking I'm looking for the e4
square the bishop might be able to come
to f5 or g4 and depending on obviously
not a five now sure I mean it's it does
look a little bit like a French defense
exchange French white well with with
both sides castling on both the opposite
flanks I've got the thing and they are
going exactly into that bridge I've got
to think that White's you know you want
to play Knight e5 and you want to play
f3 in g4 and basically because the Kings
are on opposite flanks I want to make a
pawn attack against your king and you
presumably want to make a pawn attack
against my king but feel that White's
attack out of that is this
oversimplified though for example after
95 I can just try to exchange some more
pieces with the move Knight g4 94
definitely and I think that's one reason
that he car did not play that very
natural move instead he played work on
do you want getting out of the ship g4
men support to the e4 square and
Christian just because I feel that this
line of play is very consciously five
okay you are going to go to this way
yeah yeah I just want three exchanged
all the pieces basically all the light
let's go i pieces and then here you just
feel queen e7 i think i should be
perfectly fine maybe even slightly
better because you're kind of
overextended yeah probably I should not
have played this g4i you know again I
just feel that white is for choice
because I feel like with the with the
Kings on opposite flanks I've got a
chance of getting to your king more than
you've got a chance of getting to my
king however having said all that
ninety-five was not he Cara's choice he
just played rook on d1 te one
sidestepping Bishop g4 because again
ninety five would be the response and
how how to judge this at this point I
look at the G Foursquare yeah but I'm
looking at it for my night okay because
you no longer have the pawn on h2 you
can no longer shoot him away from
general with the move h3 so I just
stable it on g4 stabilize it
you're not afraid of well Knight g5 + f3
that's fast maybe I should start with h6
first okay from the very start
h7 h6 well now and again I drew for okay
so let's say I go and again all I'm
trying to say is that with the Kings on
opposite sides and I'm gonna play for
pawn storm g4 oh yeah that I might not
aleast a little bit faster your King
looks much safer yeah in this case that
is true maybe see 5 c4 because my pawn
is oh well it's a it's an intriguing
attempt I wouldn't say it's a massive
novelty or
massive play for something but at least
there's some imbalance going on it's
exactly the type of game that he Carly
is looking it's risk free and if you
make slight mistakes exciting accuracies
you're going to end up in trouble
by the way I do think Knight e4 Knight
94 h6 or anything like it's 94 on the
board right
door Fabiana knows his theory uh-huh
okay so the cleanup were there's the
night f2 doesn't work because you're
just gonna play what like well we have a
lot of options let's have some fun of my
intention was to sacrifice are you gonna
vote you could have also just played the
prosaic Knight g5 probably yeah yeah the
Rickson the Knights had taken me okay so
you're right I could have just played 95
and made it a little bit simpler so
don't play Knight up - so Queen f4 okay
you attack my queen my queen post up on
f4 are countering an attack against your
knight there don't blunder a tactic like
oops oops no Queen b6
okay so f6 Queen f6 you don't have the
rookie for a tactic anymore cuz that
Queen is protected on f6 right okay so
tonight thanks takes and something again
this looks pretty lame that's the
question I'm not sure how much does
white have in this ain't no dream again
Knight g4 should come on the board and
most likely exactly because I
remembering the game between Magnus and
he's actually going into the other
variation he played the move Queen at
four he did yeah and I remember the game
between Magnus and Fabiano played here
in st. Louis during the sync felt Cup
where it was an ending where Magnus
ended up moving his rook in getting in G
for the famous shish yeah okay but we do
have on the board Queen f4 Queen f6 very
decent move by the way you you Christian
wanted to say that in this case you
thought Knight g4 he didn't go Queen f6
you dig those Queen f6 and you thought
Knight g4 was the right yes try it
generally tries to be exchanged all the
pieces and right I mean that's what by
the way they're just going right into
this and they are both really moving
quickly Jennifer just okay by the way
just everybody wants
it's the 30-second delay it's not a
30-second bonus so the delay they could
they're not gaining the time but you
think they would want to use their delay
there just begs the question actually
willing to trying to make a quick
drawing and just go to the rapid and
blitz I think he's just played King
Siwon as it did yeah I mean I think a
lot of people thought before the game
that you might want to just take it to
wrapping in blitz but maybe he's gonna
fool us off but that was of course
Magnus's strategy too was he wanted to
take Fabiana to the rapid tiebreaker we
know that in blitz what a monster
both mvl and he Karla by the way that's
how Hikaru became the number one seed
now Christian didn't he have like he
wanted a places back-to-back in Paris
and back in st. Louis yes and in Leuven
no I think he got second place in
Littleton very very good remember this
is they're gonna have to do a three move
repetition to make a draw so oh yeah
there's no drop yeah let's go check back
in oh this is actual that will happen
that's where we just look at that the
score in in Paris oh boy that was a big
guy that was a big result but then again
in Leuven actually Fabiano healthy zone
and he actually make the Nakamura quite
convincingly two and a half to 1/2 yeah
yeah I mean I don't think I think that
you know after you play magnets and wrap
a bag Nakamura can't seem that scary why
it might be a tough way but once you've
done 20 pounds more than 8 again we'll
just come back to our other game nothing
has happened nothing has to happen no 4
managed to take a look at I was I was
looking at a few games there is only
like 5 of them in total and the last one
has been played actually this year by
two young grandmasters
and that was actually won by black he
played them overnight thanks d4 and I
think after Knight d5 Bishop a4 follow
up try to attack this move Knight to c7
try to take advantage of the fact that
your dark squares are a bit weakened on
the Queen side and obviously you don't
have I have a big lead in development
and white there is a his own big Trump
in this transition but C takes d4 is
also a move and most of the times white
in this position plays the move Bishop
takes c6 ok he's not going to follow up
by giving up the pawn by allowing he
black to maintain his phone with Knight
to c6 he wants to take it immediately
whether we're going to see that or not
that's going to to be left to the
players but I have a feeling Aronian has
some ideas because to be honest I don't
like giving up the bishop pair like this
we should take c6 it seems like it
allows black to stabilize but actually
Bishop to d7 the knight to c6 g6 it
doesn't seem like you have all the
pieces necessary to create a huge attack
in this position so maybe he's going to
go Bishop takes c6 maybe he cooked
something else you're at home we're
going to have to wait and see but at the
moment it seems like a vast year is
definitely surprised by his opponents
opening choice
exactly speaking of home cooking for
just a second I mean I like d4 as well I
mean that was Jennifer's a knee-jerk
reaction d4 looks good but take the move
d4 back for just a moment and in this
position before just having a different
if you're gonna sacrifice a pawn you
know here here's my intention I want you
to take on bishop or before it's
definitely a good 5 yeah and when the
engines like it okay it looks like a
very nice right because yeah I mean
we've all we all like the wings gambit
it's an improved version all your pieces
are out to you you just have to go g3
not even g3 maybe even h4 h5 and get the
root out this way right okay but I like
this yes for and and again you say there
was a recent game where d4 was played
and Knight takes d4 Knight takes d4 it
was great okay
Knight takes d4 boy that's another move
with a knight
I know this is an opening circus there
are other pieces of the army just one
night
yeah I'm just worried about like just
move like Bishop e3 and then if you play
Knight f3 oh you play like knight of
three Queen f3 all my pieces it should
be going to take that 7 oh it's not jack
right there Kings anyone yes yeah yeah
you can't allow the the old Bishop takes
96 yeah just sit on the knight on d4
develop develop a sensible choice mm
sorry after Knight takes d4 and that
also I think it was 95 but the main time
to reach at 6 right I was going to give
you the old heave-ho that's weird
that is weird I think we want to play
like I want to find a way to play
something on the c7 square
you know either Bishop f4 immediately or
night before it was played in a game or
followed by like 95 that looks dangerous
yeah that much that looks much more
sensible more this is how the games
absolutely yes please shop to have for
Knight to c6 Knight to d5 obviously
attacking 796 Bishop g3 Bishop d7 and as
we can see black is still a little bit
cramped
all right but white doesn't have a clear
way of bringing this rook into into play
of course he played the move h4 rather
than h5 and ruk ruk age 4 and so on
but if black manages to stabilize this
position then he's just going to be a
pawn up if you manages to get this
Bishop out from Earth
maybe by via g6 though he has to be very
careful that's why white played the move
h4 potentially aim that if he plays g6
I'm going to go h5 and try to open it up
on the kingside where are you going to
put your King Black has to answer a lot
of questions and if he's not familiar
with out with this line he's going to
have a very difficult time doing so well
it's funny because that's a challenge
that would be right up MBL's alley if
you could just continue your line there
g6 h5 Bishop g7 as a green fell player
yourself mm-hmm
you may appreciate the nice diagonal
that the dark square bishop is
absolutely absolutely the the question
remains will you be able to actually
keep this bishop on the diagonal we
should g7 let's say I just defend the b2
pond do I even have to defend a bit upon
maybe I'm going to give you another you
wanted to push me you're welcome to push
it just a reminder to everyone that you
can interact with us using the hashtags
grand chest tour and London chef classic
mm-hmm so if you have any thoughts and
you have something really clever to say
tweet us cuz maybe we'll read it over
the air
absolutely so I've got active abirami on
is actually here doing the grand chef
story there's a lot of exciting points
that she's making as well she's kind of
highlighting key positions interacting
with users so if you have a question for
us or frittata hash tag or tag Akron
Jeff door very very nice I have the
position that you wanted Christian out
of my board I think we're going to have
to use your board okay that's amazing
and you wanted to say h6 so you're
challenging me to take the pot to be one
yeah and move my bishop I don't know the
question is where yeah you're gonna have
to give me your bishop I'm going to take
it most likely or I can just take on b7
first right and some we could get some
crazy positions like this
you can take the bishop when you want
right yeah and back here after you've
played the movie six I I did have the
other choice
it's a but you're right I have questions
to answer where am I gonna put my king
III in this it just looks very ugly to
be honest I have ideas such as 95 in
this position right maybe 95 first
Knight g5 first so the idea is that you
want to yeah you want to conquer the c7
square with 97 thanks to you the bishop
support oops we're having too much fun
here yeah well I you know I got you you
know you you you want to question what's
going on and this is well also this is
where Aronian feels most comfortable
when he gets this type of crazy
positions in balanced positions and he
knows how to play them right he has
looked at them before right this is a
this is his bread and butter to be
honest and though I have living mvl is
in big trouble in this in this game well
I just wanted to say it since the move
d4 landed on the board that was probably
20 minutes ago that is uh he's taking
quite some time Jennifer is mvl on this
and quite frankly he doesn't have too
much of a choice it's either 94 or cd4
and again 94 has been played in the past
I would probably if I'm sitting this
position for the first time take with
the pawn and how would this line go
again the ship takes to e6 that's the
basics Bishop takes c6 Knight takes d4
and 934 and we've seen apparently this
is theory yes yes it has been playing a
few times and you say Bishop d7 is the
standard move preparing knight c6 and
maybe e5
and where does that how does the line
content online for you back ok please
okay can we back up out so look after D
494 I just I wasn't playing around on
the other not sure 94 and then we'll
you're doing Bishop f4 knight c6 right
yes we were okay 96 yes now after let's
do Knight takes d4 Knight takes T yeah
okay and then after Oh we'll try taking
with a knight okay yeah
and now after 95 and you want to come in
yeah and I just like this line 96 cuz
you know it's tactics always combine
with each other right right and here we
have 1970 fact 97 check with the idea
that after Knight takes even we now have
Bishop takes f7 no oh yes and the King
has been forced to give up the
protection of the Queen this is kind of
a combination of two different tactics
but really nice and the reason it didn't
work in the other line by the way was
because you had a knight on c6 right so
that defended the Queen oh yeah that's
that's how I thought of it I was like
that would be so cool if we could do
that and so you eliminated the knight on
f3 and the knight on c6 to make nice you
say exactly exactly
oh of course maybe you could take with
the the pawn on d4 instead as you were
you're not instead here you could do C
takes d4 sorry here here yeah okay
I mean what wait a minute there's this
is a potential tempo unless you have
some way of yeah I don't know queen bee
queen e5 or queen bee I don't know this
is it's new it's new for me too that's a
lot for Maxime to look at me Maxime
finally the pawn okay which seems like
this is much more practical approach
oh yeah exactly keeping e6 and e7
squares or these protected even if it
looks like a little bit of an overworked
night like it just tossing it out there
to d4 when it's performing such key
defensive functions looks really scary
right like you better have it analyzed
backwards and forwards
exactly and no MDL is certainly where
that when LaVon played the move d4
this is her home cooking absolutely
doesn't want to fall for anything but
now six is one option
there is also 94 curious no Bishop takes
c6 you you had the same revulsion that I
had was like you don't really want to
you know give up this tube to bishops
you want to follow it up with nice and
fine yeah okay so 96 how would the line
go Christian well this I don't think has
been played yet so this might be a
erroneous novelty yeah I would assume h4
is definitely a try yeah I would like to
put the bishop on at four but
unfortunately I cannot do that
what about before though I want to put
the wishbone Beto if I cannot go to f4 I
would like to go on the long diagonal
this is actually an idea we have I think
we had a very similar position or maybe
this exact I went a six Bishop b2 I'm
just wondering he took only six oh six
gosh I thought he was going to make a
sacrifice this was a plate before Bishop
to c4 and in this position white played
the move king 21 maybe he will go to g1
which absolutely should be his he's not
worthy I'm trying to understand where he
has that interesting idea
well Bishop c4 check looks like it's
going to end up giving the tempo right
back this Queen a 24 is a problem yeah
so they're playing
I have Bishop c4 check looks wrong I
would have I would assume Bishop d7 is
automatic but that is the same stem game
the one between karpachev
and shamov and he shall morph did play
Bishop c4 by the way she is a very
strong Tara Titian he's not well-known
he's around 25
70 2600 at times but he's a very very
good tour edition so he probably knew
what he's doing and in this position
karpachev played the mover King - he won
Queen to d7 Bishop to e3 Queen to d7 of
course aimed at taking this check away
from white yes
oops no not Queen d2 Bishop III
5/9 b3 and I don't think this is a such
a big problem for black I have the big
shocker I'm going to exchange the
Queen's and I don't think I'm going to
have huge problems in the endgame I
would actually prefer a black in this
position but a after Bishop to c4 I'm
expecting maybe this move came 2 G 1 and
we're going to have to wait oh this has
been played this has been played still
Knight to c6 Knight xt6 we're still
going to get this end game you still
have the bishop on f8 to develop so you
still need a couple of moves I do have
the route coming to c1 so potentially
Bishop to e3 or Bishop to f4 Bishop to
e3 looks very very sensible just with
the idea of playing B 3 root 2 c1 and
pressure the pawn on c6 you still have
to find a way to arrange your pieces
potentially at some point you will have
to give up one of the points and just
make use of your Bishop pairs
try to create some sort of counter play
but those things will have to be found
at the board from maxime and that's not
an easy task I was about to say I like
your previous game where the king came
to e1 and you went Queen d7 I thought
that was a nifty way to stop sidestep
the Queen a forecheck threat without
playing knight c6 so after Bishop c4
check imagine you're right that LaVon
had prepared a novelty King g1 Christian
not yummy one yeah but so yeah if you
could just
yeah but right and now Queen d7 I used
to play the Queens gambit accepted and
look forward to these types of positions
of 4 versus 4 2 versus 2 and well you
got the two bishops why is black kinda
happy about this well the bishop on c4
is still a little bit of April so maybe
I can just try to beat him away ok now
where are you going to go a 6 yeah makes
a lot of sense
I'm still on I want to go E 5 ASAP of
course let's say Bishop to e3 a
b5 yes sorry or maybe not that I went to
b3
what about this move aha so what Knight
a5
business yeah yes and I'm trying to
exchange the dark sword which I
understood if I managed to do that I
think I'm going to have quite a nice
position because this bishop is a little
bit oh yeah okay if I'm intriguing you
should take some faith this might become
problematic because you don't have this
move 64 because Bishop takes to 7 I'm
going to take the pawn on it's as well
and you're going to have huge problems
exactly and also if I recapture on f8
then you've got Knight f5 and you have a
lot of weaknesses
yeah then I've got night if you Knight
f5 isn't it wonderful to 5 attacking 7
I'm coming on d6 935 is coming on the
board this is not that looks like some
good at home prep yeah ok
so there you go all right going back
just taking a peek at the all-american
matchup Jennifer after king c1 we had
more trades okay we take C board will
take c1 can you date on the board okay
so the idea there is black wants to
cover the business squares of eight and
e 7 now that the white has the control
of the open file so King f8 so white to
play well I've been anxious to play the
move Knight e5 for some time are you
gonna use Christians recipe of Knight g4
to try to trade and make a draw could be
an idea but I don't know can you think
one each probably not
alright let's right now you should be
sitting here right well that was kind of
what I was hoping yeah not that that I
think it's that much but at least in
this case okay I have gained a little
space on the kingside that's something
to chew on a little bit I may be on a
good day King d2 I'll press so if we
start with the other idea to see an IG
for but yeah
you Christiane you you you immediately
spotted a potential issue
you were said a tribe is coming that's
just because I know you yes sir I mean
I've got membership age five okay wait a
second should we take 185 yeah take me
five absolutely let's take any five
let's do it I would take with the root
canal after King g7 I think on g6 and
then I have a ruby neverkey seven Jack
yes sweet my palm grabbing credentials
the pod lives to tell the tale
boy yeah let's say Christian
spidey-sense was tingling it made it all
possible yeah good let's try to find
something better
even after 94 Bishop takes h7 I don't
think he's dead but there has to be a
way to trap your bishop or at least try
to get the pawn back right the one on f2
is hanging as well of course I cannot
take on f2 yet because of the route to
f1 I cannot take on f2 because after
rook f1 the pawn on f7 is going to hang
us woman that's actually yeah a basic
problem you got a very problem that
that's a terrible trait for you for
black because White's rook would be
crashing through in that case he play
the move h6 by the way yes he's right
stepping all these ideas or pawn
grabbing and Yasser is okay hold on you
know from the start he started with h6
no I'm saying King f8 did he play maybe
five no he played King d2 he actually
played kingly - okay and only now came
the matrix okay
I don't think naca is actually trying to
win this one
I think he's just trying to make it all
the way to the 30th move and just
offered wait no no they have to repeat
they have to repeat okay got it
you have to look for some kind of
natural repetition but but why isn't
white just nicely better here
I mean Friday more yeah yeah but from
the amateur point of view amateur
players have been told for eternity that
they don't in a Bishop's ending you
don't want to have a light squared
bishop where all your pawns are on light
squares and he did play the move 95 yeah
so after for example Knight takes Bishop
takes white is supposed to have the
better piece right the better miner a
better Bishop but this is not enough why
I mean I'm going to 3/8 I think we're
going through change absolutely
everything and then I'll have a superior
king my king is on b2 okay Bishop d7
actually let's go Bishop e6 Bishop to e6
sure okay so let's say b4 in fact I
retreat that Bishop to h5 to go to g6
actually I will give you a better
structure if that's what you want I want
more than that
I want everything I'm I'm trying to give
you everything well you're kind I need a
bit more I mean it's it's christmas is
coming and okay so you're saying that
you're willing to give me the double
pawns and I'm just saying I think
nothing you think you'll be able to hold
this pretty easily
yes on a good day if I could get my King
te5 I probably have to start like this
though right yes but also maybe I can
just try to go Keaney to f7 now okay
then King to f6 and ask you a question
whether you're going to go g5 or not
okay well I mean I was raised on a
keeper Reuben steam I do agree I do
agree you have a slight edge yeah I
don't think he's going to be enough okay
so a keeper Rubinstein was one of these
great great grand
masters who played rook endings
amazingly well like he was a world-class
rook ending player and it was almost a
kind of a magical mystical thing that he
did in rook endings that he got some
little edge and then like for example
White's rook is really well placed and
white will play for B 3 and C 4 and
somehow he won these things you know
like as the amateur player we sit there
and say I think a car's whole strategy
for this game has been a draw suits me
fine ok I'm not unhappy with the draw
says he Carlo to himself because I
really want to get this guy into a blitz
and this is and this is the schedule and
this is what he's looking forward to
draw today with an edge keeping an edge
right and then racing to the wrap of the
Blitz is this a good strategy Jennifer
yeah I think it's a great strategy for
him but if you get something he'll try
to do he has to play a game and white is
better so if he got something he will go
for it but he's not he's not a kind of
similar to the game that 9 is plated
exactly well maybe not the rapid is the
big deal but maybe the blitz is where
because there's four blitz games in this
matchup that's right the blitz is where
he's really hoping that he has an edge
and you're gonna fit the smaller edge
hey that's where his strength that lies
let's go there and it's a long day
tomorrow yeah even though in terms of
the raw amount of time it'll be similar
to the classical games in terms of the
energy expended it's gonna be a way more
hectic and draining day for the players
so I think the idea to just kind of
relax today and you see if you get
anything if not try to sign the score
sheets and rest up for tomorrow I think
that's the strat yeah and what
psychologically it feels like this might
actually not be what Fabiana wanted
he did play the Petroff so it's his
fault but maybe he wanted he Carruth to
take some chances and and and try to
risk a little bit and then he could
counter and maybe you want to score a
full point right but it seems like he
Carlos strategy is just playing to his
strengths at this point and we have seen
the move Knight g4 by the way going into
it potentially going into that anything
that we were just looking at here we had
tried Knight takes e4 Bishop takes g4 as
a little bit unsure about your move
there Bishop age five I think that you
know allowing your Bishop your poncy get
doubled was what was helping quite a bit
but I like your previous suggestion of
Bishop d7 I was going to go
b4 again I think that White's four
choice I don't know how big it is I
think it's actually not that big a deal
I'm just saying that for amateur players
they've been taught that this Bishop is
this pawn structure and Bishop ending is
superior for why this can become scary
that's right it's just there's little
nagging things the King is a little bit
better the rook is better the bishop is
better and I think that's the main
problem the fact that the King the black
King cannot go to d6 if you would be
able to get this eccentric in a magical
way yeah it'll be great easy that would
be great that will be a draw no question
I think that that's right so but what
are you three wife after f3 I tried to
go Bishop to e6 with that specific idea
of going King g7 King disease and just
hightailing quickly your king to the d6
square okay so I need in a sense to open
up the position a little bit somehow so
I'll play b3 with the intention of c4 I
can just imagine I can't help that I'm
thinking of the Maurice Ashley now I
what he would be saying about this game
boy put it to rest
come back tomorrow what else would he
say well maureesa by the way he was
gonna be back for the final yeah I think
you would have you wouldn't be surprised
because I think then not that it's not
that shocking that that this opening
occurred right the peshan yeah yeah it's
not that shocking that Nakamura went in
this route but as you continue to
analyze he'd be like come on it's a
dress yeah okay and what about game to
Christian that one is uh still in the
realms of theoretical knowledge for
Aronian which is quite obvious because
he's just blitzing every single move but
in this position once again last year
took the offensive and I played the move
Knight to c6 he wants to get his pieces
out as soon as possible he doesn't want
to lose time with Bishop c4 then defend
that Bishop then move that Bishop around
no I want to get my pieces out Knight to
c6 Knight a c6 at all costs
even in this position after Knight takes
c6 you're going to creep up my structure
after Knight xt6 B F takes c6 but I'm
going to be able to get this Bishop out
on the long diagonal we are g6 Bishop to
g7 and actually make use of my superior
light piece so after Knight takes c6
Queen - Queen takes the one which I'm
not really sure whether it has been
played or not but I think it has Knight
x d1 f takes c6 this is the position we
currently have on the board and black
has one weakness and that is his pawn
his double pawns
if he manages to get his Bishop on the
long diagonal Jesus Bishop g7 King to f7
and centralize the rooks I think his
position is going to be more or less
okay white needs to find a way to create
another weakness but let's go well I was
about to say he Karl and fab you've just
been blitzing out their moves like no
problem right there was a after Knight
g4 that was a quick trade on g4 did he
carves and I kicked you for Bishop tht
for c2 c3 and what you had said you want
to put as black you wanted to bring the
king
to the d6 squared Christian so to do
that you have to cross the file the rook
rook trade was offered and I believe
rooks were captured there okay
and now we're in this King III and so
it's not like they can just make it to
move 30 so we'll have to find some kind
of natural or unnatural repetition in
order for this to be drawn but you're
you still feeling like Nakamura has
anything because of this game coming in
so quickly no I I was a little bit taken
well actually the move c2 c3 was an
indication to me right here that Hikaru
is not ambitious in fact c2 c3 is not an
ambitious man I thought f2f if you have
ambition you're going to play b2 b3
followed by C force to open up the
position that's why another way would be
potentially to bring the rook we had the
third rank so you still don't have to
play the move C 3 you can go rook to e3
bring the bishop out and then row 2 B 3
try to create some more weaknesses why
okay so but the move c2 c3 from to my
taste was a kind of indication that he
Karl really was not playing for an edge
now after this move King III of course
on a good day he would like to play King
f4 try to secure his King in the center
and I was just thinking well maybe just
the move g5 to completely shut down that
idea that's one way absolutely you if
you put your pawn on f6 and as you say
Christian put your king on d6 you've got
nothing to fear and I think this is what
Fabiano is contemplating right now he
can also just play the move King to e7
and then after King to f4 I'm going to
retreat my bishop go Bishop to e6 and
then f6 and g5 it's the same plan but is
that so clear like for example let's say
I go here
okay f6 f6 let's
I take take h5 he did play them over g5
did Fabi because on a good day if why it
ever gets his King to f5 it might be a
little tricky absolutely I think I have
equality with the move at five ranking
of six King e6 but okay I understand
what you're saying I remember a game it
was between actually number one and
number one in the world Magnus Carlsen
versus Hui Fon it was a king and upon
endgame from a Tata Steel where he
tricked her and good Magnus but in this
case it was on the Queen side and he
snuck his King in - in this case it
would be the g6 Square and Magnus has
won against the number one woman's
player in the world but I thought g5
shut it down and by the way he did play
g5 right yeah he did they changed g5 g5
was played and now he carries trying to
find the repetition nice nice okay so
this game is definitely headed the way
of the draw
take us back you know it's funny of you
like I mentioned maurice earlier he
loves the word snoozefest news face yes
also I think that you know over the
years we've been wrong so many times
about games that we're gonna we okay no
no Maurice and I have been wrong you've
all thank you I like the truth the truth
we've been wrong sometimes about games
that we thought were totally winning and
totally drawn but somehow this point I
think the money is good yeah yeah I
think I think so this news this one is
going to end in 10 to 15 minutes at the
most
I want to say okay and LaVon has
happened in that one and we will have to
just gather our forces and try to
understand what's happening in this
position try to analyze this endgame
deeply because to be honest nothing is
happening I understand this move Bishop
were to see to it has a clear idea
behind it and that is
voila the move g6 or at least make it
more difficult to comply with because
after Bishop to c3 you're going to have
some difficulties you cannot go Bishop
g7 of course that's going to be lost you
have to go Bishop rook to g8 but after
Bishop to g7 when we're going to
exchange those bishops you're no longer
going to have the strong beast on the
long diagonal and also your rook on g7
is not looking very pretty you're going
to have to spend some time to get it
back into the game so obviously Bishop
to d2 has some clear ideas and maybe
after Bishop to c3 black just simply has
to go with a move e5 and try to get the
King to e6 put the King to d6 then of
course Bishop to g7 is once again
available maybe even ecigs and try to
get the bishop out this way the problem
with a6 this pawn on e5 is are not going
to be easily defended by the king so
that's going to be a weakness forever on
the other side with the pawn on e6
you're controlling a lot of the central
squares especially this is important
d5 square because the knight cannot land
on d5 you cannot allow the nitrile and
on d5 if that happens that night is just
going to control so many squares is
going to have so many threats at his
disposal and white-ish was going to be
clearly better we're going to have to
wait and see what what mvl comes up with
but I think he's a good defender and I
think he's going to be able to hold this
one well good the time there's one thing
I mean but he's going to he's definitely
being forced he's going to suffer on the
defensive and I'm a big structure guy I
like what LaVon has done and we'll just
see the players are the players are
trying to figure out how to make a
repetition and I think you're not sure I
dare a third one oh you're there a word
they think after 30 years they can claim
a draw they totally drawn uh-huh no no
this is the repetition
they're so creative check it out I mean
these grandmasters are amazing look what
they came up with Bishop d7 Bishop
Seaton
yes oh it's magic
so there you go
okay so instantly the to classical games
Hikaru wanted to avoid this yesterday
live yesterday Alejandro was telling us
that Fabiana was going to win the match
because he was going to score in the
classic I set this up for us and that is
I didn't say that's why I gave he
colored the odds because there's only
two classical games and he only needs to
defend one with with a black scissors
which he did in game which he did and
after that it becomes so much easier for
him because with the white pieces he can
neutralize the petrov well anybody can
well I don't want to say anybody yeah
but uh you know it's not very difficult
to get the draw against the petrov now
that's why I was expecting potentially
from Fabiano one c5 and and the Sicilian
I think that would have been a better
strategy but obviously he has he's very
confident in his rapid skills he's still
tied in the grand Chester with Hikaru in
the rapid unfortunately for him in the
blitz
he's kind of overwhelmed so he's going
to have to do really well in rapid he
has some experience coming from the
World Championship match we did do a lot
of training with rapid games and so on
so I don't think he feels inferior to
Nakamura in that time control when it
goes when it goes to blitz though I
think you need to be very discontent I'm
giving poppy a slight edge in the rapid
and obviously he caught an edge in the
Blitz well wait a minute I'm not giving
a car an edge in the [ __ ] blitz I'm
giving him an enormous vegetable sorry I
mean no I Carlos really is a beast and I
mean as far as I'm concerned only Magnus
and MBL really can hang with a Caro and
fight in the chest recently and chest
comm they had the the blitz championship
and the finals was was between Wesley
and Hikaru
and I think Wesley is a magnificent
blitz player but and Carl handled him
very well Tom he dominated
No
dominated that tournament did he carve
all throughout the tournament he
dominated against Hui fan he dominated
against MVL and he dominated against
Wesley so in the finals and they
separated when it became the bullet
section the one-minute section and he
shows how how good it is but let's go to
London because Alejandro has naca all
right well thank you guys Here I am with
a man with a plan hakuro Nakamura what
did you think coming into the game
played pretty much all the best moves
there he a Tim Bishop c5 early doesn't
offer much and at this point it's
already just very there's not much I can
do so I just play it up 54 kind of
hoping maybe Fabiano wouldn't know to
play 94 but whether this is whether he
knew this from proper even though it's
not it's not hard to find out about it
yeah I just peered out into drama not
very sorry
now you were saying before the mattress
started doing before the classical sorry
you feel very confident about your
rapido blitz and the rating seems to
indicate that you do very well in those
systems do you feel just satisfied with
the two draws on classical I mean I'm
satisfied with yesterday I was under
pressure I called I would have liked to
have gotten something more today but I
mean but foggy I was coming off the
match where he had a lot of time to
prepare so you're not really expecting
to get my child
and I mean obviously in rap the things
are a little bit different and like my
chances but we'll see how it goes
now I remembered the Wesley so mentioned
in the sink filled cup when Maurice
asked him well why didn't you try harder
against the petrol and he said what am I
supposed to do do you feel like you're
getting a little bit of a wall here as
well everyone switch to that now Fabiano
has basically proven the power off the
gun is completely fine so yeah it's a
very solid open like many different
things in 1845 so what you do well Thank
You Carl
we'll see much more action tomorrow for
sure so we have two Rapids and four
blitz and we'll good luck thank you
thank you to Cara for sharing your
thoughts easy day at the office for
fabbi that's right well Bobby I mean
can't be I don't know I mean I think
that he maybe wanted average Dame
because then he'd had the chance to
become the number one player in the
world
sure and I haven't crunched the numbers
but will he still have that chance
remember definitely has the chance you
feel like a champion has a chance yeah I
don't wanna get another match well yeah
lose this match but he's going to get
another night yeah but then spring sense
if he draws the first game and wins the
next one you might need to be more
difficult yes Alejandra we'll have to
ask him and I actually think that Bobby
would have well I he could have played
the Sicilian but there are ways to
neutralize the Sicilian and play like a
less it's not like he Sicilian and it's
gonna be an open he needs to win both
game that's what yeah that's that's what
I thought or maybe the first game would
work as well to get him temporarily over
it or the life or anything was and then
if he makes a draw I think he goes back
to number two mm-hmm but we do have all
a hundred answer some of these questions
what did Bobby want today did he get it
alla
Alejo is with Bobby
Thank You genin Here I am with Fabiano
Corona Bobby what did you want from the
game coming in today I hope for
something a little less dry well ok so
why didn't you play the Sicilian well
it's not really my job to create
excitement with black is it I mean with
white I try of course yesterday was a
game where both of us had chances okay
it was a very sharp game but I mean you
can play the Sicilian you can play
anything and and white can steer the end
towards equality but with the slightest
bit of caution so also in this line I
mean it's opposite side Castle and it's
pretty much a dragon the feeling that we
all got from the game if we both start
attacking it gets really exciting
no and y can go for the attack here so
tell us a little bit more about which
lines in this position might get a
little bit sharper than what the game
actually showed us well I mean okay why
can I like Bishop d3 instead of king b1
this gets very sharp usually in this
position instead of can be one Bishop d3
immediately yeah or h5 or smoke that you
have a possibility and also after Bishop
c4 there's like Bishop g5 which is
pretty sharp because I have to play a
six and then that we go and you can
start to imagine how others can get
exciting there's a lot of imagination
well I mean you can start to see maybe
sacrifices on a chess Evan or things
like that happening right um so yeah it
can get interesting of course it's
dangerous for both sides when because I
mean black takes some very clear
tactical risk but also White has some
strategic risk appeals block as a center
and the game I think we just followed I
think Eric and Geary um is queen of six
and I don't remember how that game went
but it was very similar we have six here
right I think it was the game I might I
might be mistaken but it was something
like this from a rabbit or a living or
fairs okay
and yeah there's there's not a whole lot
going on it seems like at that point it
was a little bit not so good
perhaps we can get your impressions on
the other game that's still going on
right here between Levon Aronian at
Maxine of a holograph it seemed like
Maxine was very surprised by this move
d4 I don't know if you're familiar with
the variation case a little bit about
what your thought process would be not
really knowing d4 and seeing it over the
board I mean the problem is I know the
Hoos so once you have some knowledge of
the position it's hard to know how you
would play if if you didn't know
anything about it but okay the way he
played is it's safe in the sense that
you know you're not going to get blown
off the board but you're also accepting
a slightly worse ending right I guess
Bishop c4 instead of Knight to c6 is a
move or yeah we were looking at
Christian was mentioning the Bishop c4
has been played before it was two
possibilities King e1 which has been
played before in a grandmaster game of
King G window via novelty looks more
natural because I'd like to get my King
deja to order g2 g3 King's utility three
King G 2 H 3 you want I guess I'm trying
to get into f2 eventually after you can
have two buddy ok G one kind of feels
more natural Wow Bobby two draws here in
the classical chest you feel confident
going into tomorrow yeah I mean I'm
actually kind of happy that I didn't
have to suffer today I was hoping for
more excitement more content but it's
still I mean you know I could have also
been put under a lot of pressure so it's
still a good result
oh thank you for an O and good luck
tomorrow thank you and guys we go back
to the studio if you wanted more he
wanted more action by the way I did get
a message from Maurice Ashley so instead
of speculating on what Marines would say
about snooze fest we'll be giving that
game credit Wow
traveling from thousands of miles away
he mentioned classical chess at the
Super jam level is it in crisis well I'm
sure we will be hearing more maurices
thoughts on that because he's gonna be
joining us for the finals
over to you Christian is classical chess
in crisis no I don't think so I actually
love the match the world championship
match system right now maybe we could
eliminate the rabbit Ibrox I don't agree
with that what my idea was is that we
played 12 games or 16 maybe we could
make it a little bit longer and go to 16
and after that if it's tied then we go
to mini matches still classical we keep
it classical all the time we go into
mean matches to game any match if no
player wins that mini much then we go
into sudden death and whoever wins the
next game is going to win the world
championship match and we go into one of
them Falls that doesn't go so to speak
that is my that is my idea that's going
to eliminate the rapid tie break so
there's no not going to be any sort of
debate in terms of who's the best
classical player and who's the best
rapid player because we have World
Championships for a rapid and blitz as
well so I think that's going to to be a
good change but of course there's so
many ideas floating out there we're
going to have to wait and see what the
feeder is going to come up with for the
next cycle Thank You Christian let's go
to just get his thoughts on Alejandro is
classical chess in a crisis its
classical chess in a crisis well nobody
can nothing so at all okay well it's
difficult because we've seen a lot of
draws recently but I think we've also
seen a lot of excitement we found a
little bit of bad luck in the sense that
we don't have the decisive results and
that seems to capture a lot of attention
but if you see the games themselves
they've been incredibly interesting okay
perhaps the game today not so much but
the games that we have yesterday were
really really cool the games that we had
a very new World Championship were
awesome we've had the seen field call
which produced a lot of decisive games
they produced some masterpieces I mean I
remember very specifically games like
for example Levon Aronian and against
Alexander Chris Turk that was such an
signing game I think that classical
chess is far far from that even I that
I'm a strong advocate for faster time
controls I think that there's always
going to be a place for classical chess
and I don't think it should give way to
different type controls just because
it's called dad I think there's so much
to explore and I agree with most grass
masters here I think that it is very far
from being completely explored we have
so many new ideas we have different
engines breathing new life to so many
different openings and it seems that
there's a couple of barriers here and
there we've seen a lot of drum berlin's
we've seen a lot of drone Petrov's but
check out this game for example and
viola I guess Neronian how interesting
can you get how many problems you can
pose a player of this caliber even early
in the opening and I wanted to take a
look at what happened and Fletcher
inspired in this game quite quickly we
have this English variation that has
been seen by LaVon white often and it's
interesting that even in a position like
this in the sense that it's been
analyzed so many times we have engines
that analyzes positions we have seconds
and look at them you still can surprise
somebody of the strength of magazine
Russia allograft even with very basic
ideas things that come from the old
Russian school of trust I was talking
through some custom jonov and he was
mentioning a famous book by Zaitsev
called a breakthrough point how in
positions in which you target as player
a specific square just so that the
opponent cannot make a breakthrough if
that breakthrough is achieved your
position sometimes collapses and you can
see that black has sacrificed quite a
bit of development in order to gain
control over the square d4
yes he's also managed to avoid kingside
castling but the main point is a d4
cannot be achieved and you see it on the
board and there's a couple of things
that go through your mind first of all
knowing that if d4 is achieved for free
your position might just collapse second
that why haven't I looked at this
position it seems like such a natural
move to consider it seems like a little
bit of a gap here by Maxime not to have
considered the move d4 you mentioned
Fabiano mentioned that he had already
looked at this move so it has been known
in the Grandmaster circles and after CT
for Bishop e6 Bishop e6 94 I think
maxime really shows his strength here
because Bishop c4 check which is a very
natural move to save the bishop gain a
temple force the King to move it's
something that Aronian has obviously
considered and it's very sharp it brings
the bishop to a position where Queen on
a4 might be a danger and instead he goes
for the practical track he has steps a
worse position but he is able to
basically neutralize White's position
and I really like the approach that he
has we'll see how this game continues I
think it's gonna be a long game in which
our owner is gonna be really pressing
but for now let's go to a little feature
as we ask the players what they thought
of this tournament's format do you
believe that tournaments would
incorporate different speeds or blitz
rapid and classical should be kept
separate I think at the moment you're
seeing more blitz and rapid events
happening so I think I would like to see
a blunt blended mix of all three because
I think for spectators it's also more
interesting as well so I think seeing
all three is great
I think certainly for things like the
World Championship match it should still
remain only classical but for these
sorts of events I think seeing a bit of
everything just to see see what works it
makes a lot of sense but I don't mind
this this format where we we mix time
controls and and you have to show good
play in all time control sample of
results I mean I think it's quite - it's
a bit different but it's pretty nice to
me to try something different I mean we
already have some sort of combinations
with repeat and blitz events even if
it's two separate events it happens at
the same time here of course it's a new
experience to have emerging different
formats I think it's fine I think
players I mean are able to adapt to
these challenges I think having
different time controls is kind of fun
not only for the players but also for
spectators you kind of get respect
there's to feel a difference they will
understand what they like better it's
impossible to be in bad form in blitz
chess while at the same time being in
good form in classical chess and vice
versa
yeah yeah very often you'll see that
players who like I play a preliminary
blitz event and do badly they go on to
play very well in the classic event and
vice versa and I've seen this many times
I've had like very blood very bad blitz
events and then got on to to win the
tournament and sometimes I've had good
blitz events and I'm performing
miserably in the classical chess
sometimes form carries over but usually
it seems like the separate time controls
are just and you can play well and one
about it the other and it doesn't there
is no correlation
hey Dobbins all the time I remember when
demo we had a pretty big song in
classical and I was winning every bit
stream that I was playing in so yeah I
guess it's possible I think so
because when you play blitz then if you
had a bad sleep then probably you will
not do so well well in classical or
rapid you you have more time to recover
you can start slowly and then be be in a
normal state but I'm quite a middle of
the thing oh it's very easy I think for
most people that is the case generally I
think when you look at the rapid and
blitz events
in the ground chest or Paris as well st.
Louis you saw some people play really
well in the rapid and blitz and really
badly in the classical and vice-versa so
I think it's very easy just because the
skills required in in blitz especially
you just sort of it's more intuition and
making practical decisions whereas in
classical it's much more about pure
calculation so I think it's definitely
possible to be in bad form and one or
the other I think come in I think if
you're if you're in bad form in all
three like Sergei was in particular then
there's just something wrong but
otherwise I think it's quite natural
today to be playing well in one and not
well
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the London chess class also the grand
chester final is where we are going to
turn these four players into one
champion yes exactly the transformation
will be completed and what high days as
we're in our second classical chess game
we will still be champions Val yes but
only one will be the grand Chester
champion and we have a game where we
think the volume is really enjoying a
long-term pull and MBL has just captured
bishops traded bishops pardon me Bishop
takes c3 King takes c3 will be on the
board and during the break I was just
talking with you Christian they're a bit
about this last decision of the players
after Bishop b6 rook d1 could you tell
me why oops I better turn off my
automatic update I apologize for that
just a second that just shows that we do
have a couple more moves thank you 7 so
just here philosophically why didn't
leave on capture on b6 I mean after all
you're doubling up a second Black has
these what at the same time you're
giving me as black a target and that is
d a coupon of course you're going to be
able to put it on May 3 but then I could
potentially advance with upon B 5 B 4
try to hook that pawn on a3 and
potentially create some sort of counter
play that's all I need that's all I want
I just want to feel the taste of counter
play it doesn't matter if I'm getting
another pawn weakness I just want to
feel that I have to play for something
if you don't allow if you don't take on
b6 if you don't open up the look on the
a file I as white don't have a single
target for your pieces so he's paying
the moon fruit to d1 he's going to put
the knight on d3 Bishop takes c3 has
been played King takes c3 King e7 and I
think White's play is just so much
easier in this place
I'm going to go 93 b4 b5 displays the
night from from c6 because that's going
to have this tracing night from c6 is
going to happen at some point because
you cannot move the b7 point that's
extremely important you cannot go b5 you
cannot go B 6 because the knight on c6
is going to be destabilized at that
point so I think at some point whitish
is simply going to be a pawn up and you
can see it on the clock you can see the
suffering of a maxim basher allograph on
the clock Levon Aronian has one hour in
36 minutes an hour difference and it has
only 36 minutes left
that's a big big time difference he
spent 3 minutes since the beginning of
the game Aronian Wow
that's that's incredible and then MVL
spend one hour and four minutes well the
good news is that means it's last time
for him to suffer yes give us give us
your odds what do you think the chances
are here that live is gonna win this
game I know you think there's a 99%
chance of how suffering yes anymore oh
yeah absolutely 99% chance of strong
heavy suffering long term but what are
the chances of an actual point being
scored
yeah exactly I don't know if it's 50/50
meaning 50% to 50% of the time that
white may win 50 percent of the time
black may lose I think it's less than
that
maybe more like 30% win 70% draw with
his incredible skill and defense you
know it's funny that you say that
because I feel like when we make those
odds and predictions usually if it's a
classical game it seems like we're
overshooting the chances of a win
exactly and then in the rapid game it's
like anything you could sometimes be
under shooting like for instance that in
that game between Maggie and Bobby in
which we thought that would be a draw
and instead Magnus won that first game
at the rapid exactly so it's it's really
I'm sure it would have been a draw oh
yeah oh yeah yeah and speaking of Magnus
Carlsen yesterday I speculated is he
watching and we did get the answer and
we got it from chess twenty fours German
stream because actually Magnus
was on the german stream with yawn
Gustafson yawn of course being one of
magnets his team members so pulling in a
special favor I think during the
Olympiad as well he said after the match
I was really happy with everything and I
wasn't gonna be petty about presumably
the number one rating spot but after the
game started yesterday I was heavily
rooting for him Carter okay
honesty is the best policy absolutely oh
yeah you can't you can't call Magnus
dishonest it was always really
straightforward and honest in his
interviews and here we see a lovely shot
of him at the World Chess Championship I
think that was an Eric Rosen shot and
Eric by the way also tweeted in just
saying that he's baffled that this can
be an opening that's playable for plaque
referring to Maxine's opening the same
night has moved six times in the first
day though right so don't show your
students exactly coaches are like
getting all freaked out because one
night moves all over the board your take
Christian on this ending again we know
it's suffering for black but the draw
percentages and odds wise I wanted to
actually say around sixty forty percent
sixty two winning and 40 percent growing
this one sixty six - morning yeah yeah I
was like a 50/50 yourself yeah but you
even think is that great I think so why
so because they're rookies is coming to
see fight that that pawn on e5 is just
such a huge weakness and once you lose
it it becomes a very very difficult
position to defend whether we're going
to exchange the Knights if we don't
exchange the Knights after I'm taking it
at the pawn on e5 then you're completely
losing right if we exchange the Knights
maybe in the rookin game you have some
some chances of survival
nevertheless I'm going to push my pawns
push my majority on the Kings side and
we have pawns on both sides of the board
and that is extremely important and I
think I'm going to slowly slowly create
new weaknesses in the position and
exploit them I'm going to be honest
because I've heard that Magnus Carlsen
also chimed in
on trust 24 and he said if anyone who's
good at this stuff it's Maxime he loves
defending beep positions that was
magnitudes date okay well there you go
real real honesty okay
if you mentioning the the e5 that's
where where it's really coming down to
your mind is this e v pawn but at the
moment also the time advantage yeah okay
so black has issues no question so let
let's say I just make a move I'll just
play rook d6 go ahead and show us how
white would that's right before let's
try to be immediately okay evil and
normally speaking that's the way for
okay a for and I'm seeing that you want
to play d5 followed by Knight takes e5
and that's why I was going to put my
king on that sex okay now I think I'm
going to prepare my my advance with a
move works if I first even though I'm
kind of attracted to the fact that maybe
I should go b5 and then look to c7
potentially oh sorry King f6 so if you
had played b5 right here my intention
was to take and try to play 19 for yes
okay that makes a lot of sense okay so
your rook c5 look more frightening to me
that maybe no rooks e5 I like group c5
rook c5
okay so I'll wait I'm waiting he 5b five
defensive ideas after I take your phone
I do I do indeed
take take with the Ponte yeah so I'm not
going to think with the rook oh yes
sorry I I tell you what I missed
I I saw this position and I had it my
mind I had 93
I forgot or b6 or that or v6 so I have
to do it right back here when you had
I had to play h5 I guess I'm looking at
it yes 4 is definitely an idea also h4
first create another weakness and and
now I have the idea the additional idea
of playing G 3 F 4 correct this is
beginning to get more and more
unpleasant for Sherlock the e or
difficult and this very very static
weakness of the e5 pawn okay Jen help me
out how can I be more what flexible what
do I gotta do with black to hold this
position
this is immediately not not okay we are
up to date
well here I was a little well the reason
why I put my rook on d6 I was a little
bit worried the immediate 95 because
here there might be some trick ease with
Knight takes c6 and also with with the
King on f6 you you no longer have them
overlook the b8 in this position even
though that's a very very passive and
Julian that move you don't have it
because of 97 yes and you're right
through you're saying do you think maybe
16 you think Roxy six I'm sorry say that
bigger saying that you're saying that
after King efficacy immediate 95 wins
upon
yeah this was my fear and by the way we
are taking phone calls so the lines are
open guys as we will probably be here
for a little while watching to see if
Iranian can squeeze this endgame into a
win call us at 3 1 4 3 6 1 hi 465 you
can also use a hashtag grand chest or to
chime in as we have a lot of time now to
kind of take your questions
what's that carrier rates may apply I
think we collecting something we're not
buddies but speaking of which with the
tax tear or closing out yeah you want to
donate to the
all the fame or the same points our arms
are wide open
yes no David nation is too small or too
biggest that's right and yes just go
over to world chess Hall of Fame org or
st. Louis chess club org both 501c3 so
tax deductible yes educational tres
according to our tax code but here's one
of our my favorite to be exactly that's
from earlier in the day from a guy
Edward oh it's from a guy in Vegas who
woke up at 4:25 a.m. in Vegas okay so
that he could go for do his work out and
then watch London just classic so sweet
I Christian that's dedicated I was
considering working out before the show
but then I was like no I'm going to sit
in my bed snooze as much as possible as
Maurice would say I was getting ready
for snooze fest right and you know it's
all your fault
it worked out the games would have been
explosive fireworks the time yeah so
take a cue from Eduardo well I read like
he started them I like Eduardo so I
remember during the World Championship
match in London talk about a fan boy
Maurice was waking up earlier than he
had to because the ladies World
Championship was going on in kunti in
Russia so the time zone differences it
was like six or seven here and yeah the
Rapids remember yeah yeah but again our
congrats everyone June who ended up
winning that and exactly we actually
mentioned on the last show of the world
championships and exciting news about
the Karen's Cup which is going to be
like a female version of the Sinquefield
cop exactly ten of the top players in
the world and that will be in February
that's gonna be in February and look out
I think we're gonna have more news for
you new more news for you on that
towards the end of the show because that
will be their next broadcast Wow cool
well if I still remember with great
fondness
it was the Kings versus Queens
event this was years ago hikaru did very
well as the bed Feingold that that was a
great match I really enjoyed and I'm
sure we'll have a like you say the
women's version of the same fill Cup it
would be great to have the top top
ladies of the world coming to st. Louis
as well oh it's wonderful indeed and I
think it's so important for girls
watching the show to decide they're
seeing some female chess players female
grandmasters
I'm not not women grandmasters big women
who hold the ground mastered hey Zack so
yeah it's gonna be really awesome I mean
we can whole youth on here before to
have many grandmasters all in one place
and it'll be an awesome opportunity for
some people watching to bring their
daughters out to the chess campus
exactly fun songs can be inspired by
women as well as Marie's was so inspired
he had to wake up at 6 in the morning to
watch the women battle exactly turn
turning back to the game for just a
second well actually
welcome to the show let us know your
name thank you I didn't know what the
gentleman was asking well he had two
questions he had two questions the first
question was is
they are that magnus carlsen gets the
doesn't have to go for any cooling
qualification process as the world
champion which is an enduring debate we
always talk about the best formats for
the world championship and funnily
enough magnus himself I think actually
suggested a format some years ago that
would require him to go through the
growing exactly so it's so funny that
even the top players who would be
negatively impacted by it come up with
these formats because they think that
it's maybe just needs to change in
certain ways I I'm not sure but I'm sure
we'll continue to discuss that and then
his other question was about the top
players in chessboxing and who would be
the best guy well I mean these players
are all in fantastic shape but Christian
I'm gonna throw that to you who would be
my chess boxer but my money's on
Christian MMA yeah no of course I
actually contemplated the idea of doing
some chess boxing but I I didn't get the
rules exactly or how it works and how
much time do I have to check made my
opponent but it seems like it pays off
to be a really good boxer instead of a
really good chess player the brains to
value is a bit skewed at the moment if
the rules are going to be altered a
little bit maybe I will consider it I
know I know London has a booming sake of
chess boxing I actually went to a gala a
few years back and it was a lot of fun
one of my friends one you know he was
extremely happy Lauren's friends was
there David Howell was there a lot of
the creme de la creme from British
championship and British chess was there
and it's very exciting I am potentially
I will look to experience that in the
future but I like it
Christian I have to start telling you
about the negative for your role okay so
a negative free roll is when you can
gain a little something but not much but
if you lose you lose your brain which is
like your most valuable asset is a
that's why that's why I stopped the
well also I stopped it because I was
traveling so much this year and I kind
of miss it but to be honest I I don't
understand the negative effects of you
know getting punched in the head I'm
trying to limit that but I miss it I do
miss it I do miss the suffering that
comes with those grueling exercises in
MMA and routines and so on it's it's a
lot of fun
I do like punching people in the head
there is this also a little bit of a
sadistic satisfaction when you get
punched you know but yeah it's it's also
a very very dangerous for your health
and with all these CTE talk going on I
am trying to limit that and your face I
mean what they have been NFL sports and
Major League Baseball to a lot of
players get concussions getting hit in
the head no I know dude seriously I
think our sports are amazing I love
CrossFit I love the I don't actually
watch MMA but I see how much people get
out of it I just don't like the idea of
picturing Christian you know how many
pounds are you approximately 180 I'm
picturing him getting paired in
chessboxing to like an 1,800 player
who's like twice inside there should be
a Casas there should be a chlorine of
course I think I can get down to 160
maybe even 150 Wow
ripped talk to us about our ending I'm
having a hard time coming up with a good
defensive effort what I just saw a new
move
and that was King 56 he's trying to put
the King to defend the pawn on e5 from
this side of the board so that he
controls the square c5 as well whenever
the room is coming there potentially I
have the King closer to that rook and
maybe I could get some 94 ideas for
example after King to d6 which was
played rook to c5 can I go night before
immediately I think I can I think I can
and that's that's an interesting idea
that just simply simplifies the position
and we're going to exchange tonight so
I'm going to be much closer to equality
if I manage to exchange the Knights so
this so King the six I think is aimed
specifically against
they are playing roots to c5 now the
question is what if I just continue with
my main plan and there is to play the
move b4 b5 destabilized the knight from
c6 and then go rook the c5 attack the
pawn on e5 captured that pawn and I
don't win the game the question is
what's going to happen now
I would assume black would like to play
the move a six because after a four oh
no the computer doesn't like this
because I'm Knight to c5 and that makes
a lot of sense because after rook to b8
okay with a problem before
now you also control this square a five
so the knight cannot defend from 85
after Knight to c5 in this position rook
to b8 rook to d1 now the King is a
little bit misplaced I'm going to enter
on the seventh rank with the tempo this
is just going to be complete destruction
for blacks so it's still a very
unpleasant position I think White's play
is very easy he's going to go B for a
four expand on the Queen side displays
the knight from c6 and it's going to be
a very long night at the office for a
Maxime I'm wondering what is his time
right now how many minutes does he have
left well he was an hour behind general
22 minutes so he spent around what 14
minutes on this moment King DS that's a
lot well the lines that we were
defending with King f6 were certainly
coming up way too short
so keeping d6 at least he holds on to
that key I mean obviously you can play
Knight e5 but then softer b4 let's try
to go deeper into this endgame and try
to understand what his defense mechanism
first of all I think b4 is a very very
good move it really is and there's
nothing wrong with it it's the funniest
thing that in these positions one of the
things I've always looked out for is the
weakness get a get getting the
weaknesses on both boards both sides of
the board I would be very very tempted
to start with H
it's like it's I'm just basically saying
it's your turn you put your King on d6
it's it's excellent square thank you
very much
I'll go h4 and put my pawn on h5 gain
some square space so while I really
think before is the most consequent move
like yeah the most incisive move h4 also
attract London let's go to London
Alejandro has a special guest well thank
you yeah sir we certainly expect Levon
to be pushing this for a while
especially with this time advantage but
here I am with a very special guest
rooster named John of former feeder
world champion and now famously known
for being the coach of Fabiano Khurana
roost and welcome thank you about the
transition between being video world
champion and a coach I this transition
kind of snuck up on me I did not see it
coming I actually thought I was a very
active player and then we she asked me
to help him in the match and they came a
second smash this was 2008 was 10 30
years ago and I helped him in the match
and it took me a while to recover from
the match and then he asked you for a
second match in 2010 and then there was
a third match in 2012 and before I
actually realised I was a coach and not
to play anymore because was difficult to
keep up my playing career and also I
felt that at some point was all this
coaching and travelling and my own
strength started to suffer a little bit
like I would know so much more about
chess after working was Vichy but my
actual decision making of the board
became not quite as efficient I would
think and somehow I never made this
conscious choice that I will be a coach
but it just happened well are you as you
mentioned you have four World
Championship mattress under your belt
and three with Vichy one with Bobby
I also remember more about this recovery
that you needed is it really that
stressful well with with Vichy I felt I
usually need it about like half a year
to start functioning properly again give
or take
and that's for the mattress I want
obi-wan so I wonder what will happen now
but I feel I feel I feel good I feel
optimistic about this one because I
think I am I know some recovery
mechanisms I didn't know back then like
I do yoga agrees and it's awesome I
don't know we know a lot about the daily
routines of our players but tell us a
little bit about the daily routine of a
coach once you're in a tournament
well first rule is that you don't get
much sleep there is basically no way
around this because especially with
Bobby we kind of do a lot of things
together like we do dinner together I
would do breakfast together we do lunch
together which is not what I was doing
with Rishi for instance which means that
you spend a lot of time together meaning
that there is less time you have for
work and I usually just wake up very
very early in the morning and start
looking at something and I go to bed
late so I usually get like maybe four
five hours of sleep and then I try to
take a nap when when he's playing so my
routine depends on the length of his
games
so sometimes guys this tournament or
every game is a seven hours this is a
blessing for me because I can you know
get a nap go for a walk do some yoga do
some more yoga and sometimes because
these days that I don't like like today
like today you know I mean I just I just
get in my mouth I start doing some some
Sun Salutations and suddenly I have to
you know reach for my phone and go go
meet him somewhere
so stairwells sounds terrible and it
that what you're gonna do you think it's
a very bonding experience to be the
coach of a player um I think it depends
on the player it is of course bonding
anyway but some people qilin if it's the
right word but some people get more
intimate than others as in I have been a
second to players that didn't really
need to see me very much what they
wanted is analysis and ideas and I try
to deliver but then it's not as personal
and with Bobby we've been traveling
together for three and half years now
and and yes I think we got close yes
yeah half years seems like quite a while
and well overall how do you yourself
feel after you know being in London for
such a long time and having to come back
here
I had mixed feelings my first trip to
London was 2012 and god I loved the city
I just backed down to town 12 I played
the Grand Prix here and we stayed at the
Strand and there's just such a beautiful
location I would walk around and I would
go to museums I would go to Piccadilly I
would walk to all sorts of nice places
and for me London was always like a
pearl of the world and losing the match
he kind of creates some some negativity
as well so now for me London is
complicated so coming back here was not
easy I did not I did not enjoy driving
into London like a week after we lost a
match to tell you the truth well
hopefully this is a little bit dispel
they fought me does well in here
obviously it's gonna be having a tough
match tomorrow he faces hikaru in rapid
chess and blitz but thanks for your time
and well let's go back to the studio in
st. Louis thank you my pleasure thank
you very well-spoken obviously not his
first language Kazakh Stan but you month
I think he loves literature and movies
and stuff so like like paavada
well of course Christian would know more
than I do but he loves books and movies
so I think for many years he's been
really good at he's he's a professional
chess player he interacts yeah all the
time with english-speaking people so I
think that just builds up throughout the
years and I mean right now his his
English is immaculate
yeah I love to I love what he said just
because you know you don't often get so
much emotional content from grandmasters
metalic we made a good move it was yeah
they talk about their feelings I had a
great idea and I think that story that
clearly ties in with his love of stories
in literature you know you really you
really get that sense when you heard
that
yeah exactly yeah he's a philosopher 95
neither h4 neither before I loved your
age for a move by the way that was
awesome
oh yeah I learned something he's
hurrying up a little bit he played this
move Knight to c5 trying to create
something immediately and you know
commonly that sure played a move rook to
b8 the only move in in the position
because of course after 95 you cannot
play the move b6 because after 97 you
suddenly resign right um so after 95 d7
is not possible because 97 King c7 of
course is not possible because Knight
takes c6 and potentially this move
Knight to a5 of course is not possible
because a simple move such as root B 1
is just going to deliver the goods after
king to e7 you take I'm going to take
this other pawn as well 96:19 3 7 and
you're going to lose that Knights M game
so of course b6 is the only route B 8 is
the only move in the position and the
question is how to defend this night on
c5 how to stabilize the knight on c5 and
you would have to play B for at some
point the problem is right now you can
you cannot play before because Knight
things before come on the board you
would love to play a three and then
before and then rook to d1 and invade on
the seven seventh rank the problem is
after a three I can probably just play
the move a a five stop you from playing
before and I don't see the follow up
what is this Knight doing on c5 how are
you going to stabilize the knight on c5
because that's what night-nights need
they need outposts they need stable
outposts and the knight on c5 is not
stable denied on d3 was stable and it
was actually supporting the expansion
with before I'm not her percent sure
about this move Knight to c5 we're going
to have to wait though and see what
Aronian has has planned but maybe we
will just see a retreat back to d3 and
then continue with the move before and
this is where we can guys six points for
Nakamura and Kurata after drawing both
of their classical beams three points
for aronia and certainly hungry to get
that nine as he tries to press and press
and press against next
you're the girl who is kidding in an
enviable position but as Magnus Carlsen
State and I'm sure he was being
tongue-in-cheek with young Gustav in Mac
team loves to penny magicians like love
is a relative term exactly but it's a
bomb but some people hate it less than
others that's what I mean that's true
right
Oh some people hate it so much and
temperament for I mean I in my day
Olfa Anderson was this great defender he
was remarkable in you know keeping
extremely difficult positions nobody
like that but both loved it you know
could handle it well yeah it's all about
how you sell it because you could also
say that this is this experience where
you get to show your great and your
determination right and it's a special
type of life it's a special type of
pleasure getting you know pressured and
pressured and pressured and then finally
getting the desired result
exactly - he feels Julius as winning a
game in a brilliant sacrifice but it
actually has its own special pleasure
you know it is a victory yeah I mean
stealing then half a point you know in
keeping keeping the game we do have some
moves
h4 was played your move yes sir yeah I
would thought that night c5 was a little
premature but okay h4 and then came
night to beat night before world which
is because I was just mentioning that I
want to play a 3 B 4
well is this automatic right because I'm
I can't believe that MB I would want to
bring his knight back to a6 I'm trying
father said okay okay I think what
trying to play United b6 hard me b6 yeah
you 7683 b6 by the program after night B
well can't they you can take but then I
will take on c5 and that endgame is not
looking that easy because you take with
the pawn on c5 I go King c6 and you have
to defend on the b5 and then I have work
b5 rugby five as well it seems like I'm
getting enough counter play to a really
nice little in between are their endings
I'm not sure but okay b6
it's okay so what after b6 q something
else Knight d6 taking a different pawn
now the question is after night through
eight - yeah
misplacing your rock that's what I
wanted to do what did you know when you
take on e6 and go on the C file and take
over the C file you say so what do we
have here you're gonna be able just like
King D 3 and B 4 and we can reroute your
roof I mean this is still a healthy pawn
right healthy ish yeah yeah just me that
you got like one tempo to play d4 or
whatever or d8 again yeah I mean I'm
okay but from the start if you had
played b6 I would actually like to just
retreat by Knight to a4 okay okay so
we're trying to go 93 and 95 alright so
when I go b5 myself that is true
finally only nah I would prefer my
knight on d3 night before
there are you Treviso 94 yeah night
before a 3 B 6 I think maybe we'll see
that line with 96 because that look the
votes promising to me I'm just oh okay B
5 B 5 that's an or a5 a5 a5 a5 just
trying to clean maybe horn but b5 what
was that why did you reject me 5 well
they didn't you see the engine
you just jumped yes sir I did it I'm
sorry I'm just trying not to make a fool
of myself here no I think the problem
with this one is look to see to and then
a before if before or a 5 I'm going to
go Rudy - you're going to lose the pawn
on e5 and I'm also going to invade on
the d5 that's annoying good point
ok so you had the idea of a 5 perhaps
and then if I go into the rook and I be
like a key I'm not going to be afraid of
that I mean I'm actually very happy with
that
I'm going to go night before we're all
going to exchange b5 I think this is
more than enough - for equality well you
the trade of knights really assists
black absolutely ok absolutely I think
that that's a fair assessment except
when we get a free pawn I mean I feel
like that line to me that seemed the
most promising which point three maybe
696 I like that about cuz I didn't feel
like black had enough confidence yeah
let's try the bill deeper into that line
is root 3/1 the only move I guess it is
yeah it looks like the only move oh
because because the light is trapped
like if we were to flavor see the way or
something
even just giving up the night with the
moon roof to c7 but that's yeah that's a
bit crazy
well first of all it knows 3d - what
about King 2d - no no no I mean I you
want in there I want to trap your knight
and have an active rook well so what
about King so if I play King g6 you
probably have to just plays rook to c2
and try to trap my knight no okay you're
gonna graph it and now after Brooks he
you're just getting so many pawns but
that's a that's a knight
that's oh here you know that's my idea
nice you wanna know now now black is oh
he's getting enough condoms no the night
I am having like four points no no this
is interesting but the other option is
instead of playing rook takes pawn maybe
you could just try to trap the night
anyway with like look-see - Oh mister
you would see to it from the start
Oh actually wait work see 1786 I'm too
late okay I see what you're saying
no no what sorry didn't Christian I have
an idea of king d2 that we didn't look
at so night a two after night a two
rooks e7q music no that's the one we
looked at seven King e6 King D - King D
six King D 6 and then at this point yeah
I don't I don't have a choice
you can go rook to c2 but you're not
there that after before I'm going to go
night eggs before and we're going to
have equal pawns and I shouldn't have
any problem that's maybe three you don't
believe me three okay you can but then
my is this what did I gain from the
other variations where I could have just
played rook c2 from the beginning I was
Levi King position no I didn't I don't
think why we just play rook see to here
then or okay one yeah or okay wine in
with reason and just play this position
up on it is up upon so you know this
this could be a path that we're going to
see yeah it's very straightforward idea
as well but again I I mean when you play
this move Knight before it is because
after a three it's a pawn sacrifice
because you're not gonna go back to c6
because as you said Christian you go
back to c6 you wanted to play a 3 and B
4 anyway yeah so you got you got three
moves in first I think it's already
closing yeah so after a three-year every
night a six yeah you're basically
obliged to go and I go back right
well now you got maybe an ideal setup
what is the night what is the night that
I'm doing there I mean it was on a
superior square c6 and at this point I'm
also starting to consider just simply
displacing your King with the idea of
the
g3f for Europe d1 might even do you
wanna scratch ya disruption front yeah
no everything is and Jennifer the time
for I mean the Vaughn's got a big edge
on the clock that's right you see here
just 18 minutes left format Maxine by
Sheila Grubb and over an hour for LaVon
as hour and 20 minutes actually yeah
bigger than our advantage as it seems at
lavon's booths are coming easy to him so
these figures why not put him on the
pressure on the clock and on the board
these are the type of situations on the
clock where you actually have to factor
in other problems such as physiological
problems because let's say you get down
to your last for four minutes and your
opponent has another hour to think and
you start drinking too much water you
have to go to the bathroom yeah I can go
old I can think for like 40 minutes
you're going to have to sit at the board
well max he's a mathematician and he's
not even born here Christians I there's
a famous story like that between the
Byrne brothers Robert Byrne and Donald
Byrne and Donald Byrne was an hour
behind on the clock and Robert was
thinking taking taking taking his time
and the move 40 and Donald really needed
to go to the bathroom so Donald
whispered to his brother across the
board Robert please don't move I need to
go to the bathroom and Robert said
something along the lines of go to the
toilet on your own time no no guarantees
no promises you know for sure that's
also an issue you gotta keep in mind I
don't know what black is gonna do after
a three I don't have a good I think he's
just going to go with the most be six
and try to defend the route can game
with the pond out and we'll have a
lesson and working games from both the
attacking and
and inside right a 3 B 6 and you think
this is just going to go into a very
variant it's a question of passive
versus active defense and you chose the
active defense he's going to lose the
pond he pays his dues or an active
defense but at the same time you know
his route becomes active
he's going to find a path towards the
first rank
I like this by the way I like this Roxy
too much better than a rock a 1 so
something like this yes but I think
maybe now I can even avoid you coming on
the first rank with a mobile King to d2
not rook to d2 but what did you say
sorry King to data in this position
yes and now if you go route to d8 I'm
going to go king - I was thinking to see
one king to see one and whenever you are
going to give me another check King I
wrote the seat tube but the problem is
root 2 D 3 doesn't look very appealing
to me we're in this position route to d3
for black rook the d3 for black I still
don't see the mechanism to keep you away
from from penetratingly it's like black
is getting active yes so maybe instead
of king see that's what I wanted what
why don't we do that with route to be -
you don't have a good from the start
yeah we're to be - in this position I
see threatening king - C - and your idea
of trapping the trapping the route well
as we see how the same game shakes outta
the fonz actually yet to play the move a
3 but as we know he has gobs of time we
are going to take a little break okay
we'll be back for more from the round 2
day 2 of the semifinals here at the
Grand chest or finals
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like VA 3
is an illegal move here because Y
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that I have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
gotta say planking in seven games you
too
and now try because y'all play four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is that g5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we practiced I know who
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this
I don't think it does well maybe it does
well that's me regretting what I just
said how did I get from there to here is
a little bit beyond me and what's worse
I will never hear the end of my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
health care in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation ascension is made up of
physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
healthcare innovators nationwide
ascensions faith-based heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
two billion dollars in care for people
living in poverty and for programs to
help them whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the London chest classic the grand
chest for finals right now actually were
in the semifinals as we see Levon
Aronian try to take me honor of being
the only man to win a classical game in
the semis as he's seriously pressing
against Maxime by Sheila crab in fact
he's off a clear pond in the end game no
look at me
but as Christian mentioned small
consolations for Manx team include
active rook and just the fact that the
Knights are traded having the extra pawn
with Knights and the board would be
devastating absolutely no the trade of
the Knights definitely benefiting Maxine
and now we think that he's getting some
active well in fact he is getting
activity Christian is it enough because
maybe the Vaughan could have done it in
a nice I think he could have done it
much better and that is in this position
after a night - a - this won't work to
see to that we were mentioning before we
went on our break King takes c6 and now
b3 the difference with a rook a one rook
takes a two idea is that now you control
the c5 so black doesn't have this option
of putting the rook on the C file and
threatening the penetration on the first
or the third rack for example if you go
rook to the 8th maybe I can just simply
go King - E - right king - E -
controlling all the squares all your
entry squares and now you have to lose
the temple that is the problem you have
to lose the temple I would assume maybe
this is what he was afraid of night -
before a takes before and rook to d4
though my rook becomes active as well
and now I'm starting to pick up your
pawns if I pick up g7 h7 then these guys
are going to start running down the
board and it's going to be very very
difficult to to defend them so I don't
know what he missed
I don't know why he hurried with a move
route to a 1 because it seems like a
rook to c2 is such an accurate move and
these are the type of moves that Aronian
needs to find in order not to give his
opponent any sort of counter chance and
he didn't do that in game 1 he seems to
be sleeping
a little bit in Game two but of course
his advantage is still quite significant
right now he's upon up of course the
rookies rookies going to invade
potentially on the third rank
potentially on the first rank we're
going to have to wait and see what
Maxime will do he has some choices to
make
he has a very little time left on the
clock so the clock is definitely going
to he played rooks he won I think yeah I
was about to see one let's assume active
play right away they play rope does he
want a rope 2d2 was played we won rook
to d2 yeah but I mean compared to the
previous position this just doesn't seem
like it stacks the same punch you know
compared to the previous position the
one that we were looking at earlier so I
won would rooks it to be three yeah
we're a black just simply doesn't get
the Rooker invading well the first and
the third rank we know and rook endings
especially especially those where you're
a pawn down seek activity is the
defender here so here I've got two
choices in my view one choice is to go
rook h1 to hit this pawn the other
choice I would find myself attracted to
is rook e1
give me the pawn on b3 if you play rook
d3 to defend the pawn then I go check my
me chec and I will just wait and yeah
and the King now is passive right not
only is a king pass it but the black
rook is also absolutely reactive here
no the rook on d3 is not active the main
difference over the the previous line
that you were mentioning so this is the
current position and also there's
there's this move to consider the reason
I I don't think you'll play rook c3 is
because after rook b2 with the threat of
king D to to kick the rook back you're
gonna have to play rook c1 anyway but
that was the position that we started
from no they're gonna hate to yes that a
difference yeah well maybe the the
difference being that the rook is
actually better on b2 then on a2 or
whatever reasons like this so this is
our current position the work is on a to
the rookies on d2 but yeah the rook was
on a - yeah
now the rook is on b2 and maybe for
whatever reasons I can you know I can
play B for B you know what I'm saying is
my look better on b2 the native yeah
maybe it is maybe it's not that big a
deal anyway we do have rook a1 by the
way after the move I'm upset I'm very
upset at how white is playing this game
because he's just giving black too many
chances
you cannot win games like this right as
a 2800 at that level you have to be
perfect in this type of technical
situations you nobody's asking you to be
perfect and nobody is perfect in
extremely complex situation right but
when it comes to technicality these guys
need to have it pretty pretty perfect
and the thing is we have such a high
expectation of their play we do see ya
there more often than not playing
exceptionally precise moves and you're
distraught that rook a1 by Aronian
instead of rook c2 and worker could be
the difference between a draw not a
salute absolutely and it just seems like
he didn't take his time these are the
type of situations in which when you're
in shape where you you're in good shape
you're going to be accurate a surgical
precision yeah when you're not in shape
you're going to miss that final blow
you're going to miss it
your opponent is going to get enough
counter chances and he's going to escape
with a draw it happened yesterday it
seems to be happening today and it seems
to be a trend in erroneous game this
year we were discussing this over dinner
last night and I hadn't remember
besides the candidates which was just
abysmal from
from the volunteer I think he did - four
or something like that lost like 15 to
20 rating points regulars but he still
he still is the only 27 65 coming down
from almost 2800 at the beginning of the
year if I'm not mistaken right so I was
trying to understand where he lost his
rating points and I think he lost a few
at the Olympiad as well and because in
the grand chest where he played quite
well he plays well in in the same field
Cup qualifier he scored quite well in
the rapid and blitz but I guess you were
saying you were measuring Norway Norway
Trust is maybe their grand que as well
on there you see how he gets here number
two coming into this competition Jim
that's right he did tie for first in the
same field Cup and on top of that he
didn't really have a bad tournament
maybe other stuff so I got him into this
nice position
tie game tying for first in the cinco we
go back to 2013-2014 he was the number
two rated player in the world by far
Magnus was just ahead of him there was a
there was one single game where there
was a swing game where I think had he
won he would have gained five rating
points he has lost to Magnus losing
vibrating points that 10 point swing was
between first and second so this is a
player who may be at his peak was 28 37
or there's about and almost number one
that's a big fall from grace mission no
absolutely and you know he's 36 years of
age he's not getting any younger he has
to hide that final punch and go for the
world championship title because he
wants it yes he wants it so badly and
and the whole nation of Armenia wants to
have another world champion right and
that expectation seems to be weighing on
him a little bit and maybe that's the
reason why he
I'll do it after this point but in many
many interviews Magnus was specified in
fact that he's kind of afraid of uh of
his creativity of erroneous creativity
he's one of those players in the cycle
that could potentially pose a lot of
problems to Magnus but so far he's he's
not getting there and maybe these are
the type of situations that he needs to
work on or try to get them out of the
system where he hurries in these
critical situations instead of finding a
surgical precision needed very good now
having said that we are at a point where
white does have a pawn to the good yes
and certainly is hopeful that is to say
white is hopeful that he could at least
press and maybe score a victory how in
your view would white though about doing
that you're a little bit behind on your
board compared to the current position
yes this is the position we could have
on the board and I'm expecting why to
try to get his King all the way to g3
and maybe go f4 at some point maybe try
to go bring his King all the way to h3
and then play the move g3 and then
slowly slowly try to lather up and
expand on the Kings side without being
said this rook is so active all right B
to a and it's just making this route on
d3 so passive you're not going to be
able to invade because my King is safely
securing the the square d7 if you go to
c3 I'm going to go back to these six I'm
going to secure the entry on c7 so
you're not going to be able to
transition into those type of positions
where you give up on on this side but
capture all the others on the other side
you're not going to be able to get that
and that's a problem this King is going
to be tied to the defense of the pawn on
g2 that's why you need to find a way to
untie it
so eventually bring the King to h3 you
don't wanna play g3 first because then
the king is going to be cut on the first
rank you want to bring it all the way to
the third rank then play the move g3 and
then think think what's going to happen
after that for black I think he's going
to try to stop Y from doing that
getting his King active with a move to
h5 securing this entry on g4 vrg for for
the White King I I think this is going
to be an easy drop I know black is just
too active I I would like to play the
devil's advocate if I could just for a
moment
know what I think everything Christian
said was right on the mark the thing
that really surprised me was this move a
7 a 6 I thought what you said with h7 h5
made perfect sense but when I saw this
move a 6 I'm thinking you want to age 5
I will play h5 it makes a lot of sense
and then I will do what you said which
is I'm not gonna have my King trapped on
the first rank I want to go King to G 1
to H 2 to H 3 just as you said then I
play the move G 3 and then I'll put my
king on g4 thanks to the fact that I
have my pawn on h5 let's try to take it
one step back ok fine I'll start with h5
b5
very good I want through and we'll trace
solidify that punim b3 your weakness on
beat it
we're gonna trade that one and I will go
King G 1 and you on yes
let's go b4 as well okay so you gain
space well done
and now King f6 now I think it's time
and I'm ready to go king of six my poem
b4 seems to be quite threatening if you
decide to sacrifice the poem III fair
enough King h3 King g5 Wow okay so now
we get to go here right what if I go
King f4 okay maybe I'm becoming too
active for my own good wow wow well we
never thought you could play this badly
okay unless you want to give me a
checkmate no I don't like this one I
don't like this one I don't have enough
counter play with or with a beep on but
in this moment when you
you could have just taken my pond and
you're you're gonna end up getting this
guy a Christian I mean you have given me
yeah no I like this one I like this I
mean a three versus three stake I'm
going to take on be three three versus
three it doesn't seem like you have
enough so after a six by the way he did
not play that is to say LaVon after a
six he did not play h5 he just won kingi
one right away
so again would you be 5v5 immediately
okay okay we're gonna see a trade trade
and again I would I would play h5
personally but let's see if we can't
channel the players a little bit better
alright King page 2 - I assume before he
doesn't seem to be wanting to put that
point on h5 because of this specific
reason of a king of six King g5 exactly
so let's go before okay fair enough and
we're gonna okay so I'm going to play
King h3 now I think I'm ready to play g3
and h5 in kingi okay okay okay wait a
minute
do I have them over to see - yes 63 yes
you definitely should be doing that kind
of a business let's say h5 rook c3 yes I
don't think you have enough yes sir I
really don't think you have enough
winning potentials yeah no I mean it's
my beep on is going to be a threat as
well yeah obi-wan king of six I think
I'll take the point like this yes my
ambitions might get high again
so you wanted me to be precise and take
it with ya but I don't like that to be
honest I don't like to catch one okay
I think at the end towards the end I I
was in no no danger at all of some king
of 6h 6 I will take that you take on h7
and then I'm just going to go into g5
maybe King did you maybe even came to g5
ok I want to be ambitious okay I don't
know I think it's a draw I do I do think
it's a draw and I think that I can go
ping g5 back right I have to be right
perhaps Maxine why share the ground
loves the gravel well another funny
thing that do it on his own interview
with John Gustafson is that you thought
that Cara wanna is clearly weak earth
relative to the others and ravaged as
calling Bobby style and demanding
calculate so deeply meaning that is
demanding on Viviano and you can't just
like chill and like relax and play the
moves by Byfield is that's right so that
of course shifts to that but that's one
of the reasons why it's more difficult
for him
well I saw that in two players
especially Garry Kasparov and Walter
Shawn Brown these two works
ordinarily gifted calculators and they
really really enjoyed looking deep deep
deep into the positions they burned a
lot of time on their clogs and often
times especially in the case of Walter
Brown got himself into a lot of time
trouble and that end up like they burned
out they flame out because they
calculated so deeply the demands on them
were great whereas I thought of Anatoly
Karpov that's kind of the contrary into
that that strategically he played it
played so easily that he was a great
natural player what's your take they're
they're Christian maybe what he meant by
demanding as well was the fact that
Fabiano has to put so much time and so
much effort into his opening preparation
so he has to spend a lot of time when
he's not in competition he has to spend
a lot of time when he's in competition
and Magnus for example he could just
relax during competition because he's
not so attached to his opening
preparation he's going to choose what he
wants to play given by his seconds
before the game he's going to go through
those variations for a little while and
then he's going to just accurately play
it over the board and then he's quite
confident about his middle game I would
assume this is what he meant as well a
potential other side of this comment of
being demanding to do to once one's game
the fact that he has to spend so much
time on his preparation and how about
you Jennifer and in your own play did
you see yourself as a guy and I got into
time pressure and I also felt that I was
better at the classical chess by far
let's a rapid well especially rapid I
feel like rapid was the worst because I
was like that was like an in-betweener
where you can't just well you you you
know you kind of have to calculate a
little but it's very difficult to manage
it right so I I always had a lot of
difficulty with those game 30s and stuff
at the Marshall and stuff like that
uh-huh that would be the Christmas for
the other player rating points I
remember you being a very good Blitz
yeah you know I like butts though I
like with I'll explain quickly thanks ml
the rapid though that wasn't your high
probably I think that was he in between
yeah and I'm sure there's a way to
strategize that as well so like just
think about it and like now that rapid
is becoming such an important part of
training and women's definitely it's not
an unsolvable problem if you have skills
at blitz and you have skills at
classical your you should be able to
figure out a way to play good rapid
maybe I'm not as intuitive because blitz
it's obvious the prescription play fast
played good moves fast calculate once a
game but we've got a Grandmaster
Alejandro
with a special guest from London I can't
wait to see who it is
well thank you Jenna of course we're
waiting here to see how huronian
continues his pressure against Maxine
Bashir digraph but a sign was mentioned
earlier this building greets chest coal
truck here with grandmaster from
Australia David's murder and welcome to
the show thank you well David there's a
lot going on here besides the four
players in the Grantchester tell us a
little bit about what you're doing here
yeah so I'm not actually here
specifically for the chess tournament
one of the few people not here for that
but they had a the London chess
conference which is the biggest chess
conference in the world I think with a
whole bunch of practitioners and also
educators and then people like me
researcher so we got together to talk
about it over the weekend a little bit
more about your research well I work in
different areas now so I left the chess
playing world a couple of years ago and
moved into economics and typically I
don't work on chess within economics I
work on mainly development economics and
behavioral economics so things to do
with the psychology of how people make
decisions and also things in developing
countries to do with poverty and women's
issues and that sort of stuff but when I
came here the reason is because one of
the sponsors of the tournament chess in
schools and communities they've decided
to do some work in prisons and I'm quite
interested in prisoner reform and how to
improve the well-being of prisoners and
also to help them when they get out of
prison and the organization has started
using chess in the prisons which is kind
of exciting and they've had a few sort
of programs in Brazil also I think
Illinois as well and they're trying to
get researchers like me on board to
evaluate it provide some sort of
scientific assessment and hopefully
expanded into more presence how long has
this project been going on here in the
UK I've been doing it for a couple of
years now that was obviously you can
imagine there's quite a lot of
logistical stuff to get into a prison
you've got to get approval by the
Ministry and stuff like this but they
did it they really they work super hard
here in the UK it's a great organization
and now they've got I think they've got
four prisons
might be wrong but I think it's four and
they're looking to expand it because the
each prison has loved it so much and the
prisoners they really enjoy the program
they've seen some some anecdotal
benefits that other prisons are now
starting to come to them and say hey
maybe we're interested as well let's
come in there's one guy in the UK Karl
Portman he wrote this book that came out
a few years ago called chess behind bars
kind of a nice title about his
experiences going in and some of the
stories it's really quite inspiring so
that's what sort of got me interested to
see whether I can combine my day job
with with this as well
well speaking of combining things how do
you feel that's what you consider
yourself a former trust player yeah
somebody that obviously loves the game
with going out of the chess world I mean
so I got the Grandmaster level but as
you know I'm not a particularly strong
Grandmaster so I was never really at
that sort of you know making a decent
living standard anyway so maybe it's
already a bit sneaky to call to call
myself a a former player I was just a
good amateur I guess that's just a very
strong answer but but never at the level
of the people here and actually it might
surprise people but I found something
that I enjoyed even more than chess
which I thought was not possible which
is research I have a great job I can
choose what I want to work on I've
always been pretty socially minded
trying to improve conditions in
developing countries and the good thing
about my job as an academic is that I
get to travel so here's a chess player
get to visit new countries so there's
that sort of lifestyle element as well
Oh awesome well let's take a look a
little bit about the chess with ya all
right a couple of moves I saw that you
were analyzing this with a couple other
grandmaster we got Julian hot stone in
the house we got Danny King in the house
what do you think are already a chance
of actually winning this position I mean
both these players are so technically
good that normally I'd say that whatever
the objective assessment is these guys
would probably reach it but the real
issue for me is this thing up here like
pull the magazine yes three more moves
to make it's got three more moves to
make but also I think from an energy
levels point of view you know he's at
distress knowing that he's walking into
preparation again I think that's that's
made him put in a lot of mental energy
and now he's got to really calculate
hard so I mean me and a few of the other
guys here a few of the other British
grandmasters were analyzing this way
back and about an hour ago I thought
we'd end up in an end game a real
component end game with four versus
three on the kingside that was my own
vicious prediction versus three yeah
these guys are gonna get swapped off
that's what I thought an hour ago so if
it happens then I'll Pat myself on the
shoulders and then John Spielman sort of
an in-game expert there's a legend in UK
circles was talking about this botanique
nerd-off endgame where you've got two of
us to button II porn as well we're both
feeling goes for the win which is
possible if Aronian can swap off the eff
porn for the e porn and again we're a
little way away from that at the moment
but those are the sort of games that I
guess both these players know you like
the back of their hand and they're both
trying to either get there or avoided
right of course we are building on the
great of the past and of course they
must know all these games B takes a for
has been played and a couple moves
closer for Maxime to make time control
but still a dangerous situation well
David thank you for joining us here in
London and we go back to our studio in
st. Louis thank you he loves research
more than chesty more I think you should
visit st. Louis well yes all the things
in general archive materials that are
over there well I was actually thinking
about the fact that the Chess Club and
it's classic Center like they're doing a
lot of research studies of course in
conjunction with there's some there's
some board members who are very into
research as well pod Gursky right and
dementia it does just delay
if you activate the brain or the elderly
age can you push away dementia indeed
that's one really important project
they're working on as well as trying to
do more and convincing research on chess
in the schools and about absolutely so
it just sounds like David would have a
blast in talking to people so hopefully
we can get him interesting about the
prison and there was the recidivism and
and chess of course has been in the
prison systems for so many years and I
think of Nelson Mandela when he was in
prison he loved playing chess because he
was looking to kill time
and he found that chest did that and he
had what he called good sits flush and
he would try to outweigh as a father he
got to do a bad position he would
explain but also it was just it was a
great competitive and to use his mind
absolutely when somebody asks you the
books you're gonna bring to the desert
island I would I would just say a deck
of cards and a chess board that's very
very important Christian / tu rook d8
was played by Levon kind of abandoning I
like that win side I like a little bit
and then we saw captures on a fork go
ahead please take us through yes it's a
transitional move he decided not to wait
any longer not to defend passively the
extra pawn give it back but get the
initiative and that's exactly what he's
trying to do right now I think after be
takes a four-bit I say for we have the
move route way to on the board and now
Luke 2h8 was played look AJ AJ okay
there is some more weaknesses h6 and
this is the position currently we have
on the board okay I was going on through
the through the endgame with the
computer yes and the computer really
loves White's position really don't move
h5 play for four for an active royal
position King to h2 came to h3 bring the
King all the way to g4 okay and slowly
slowly try to get your king out of e6
invaded with a king to f5 and it seems
like black is going to have a very
difficult task not allowing that to
happen so just to put some moves on the
board which are quite logically eight I
will go back to it right now because I
always want to have that check on the
side and then we get a situation like
this where as you say you want to invade
through the square f5 you can go check
and go immediately to a6 and you've
achieved the absolute ideal yes is the
dream that white wants when he played
the move rook h8 the current position
this is done amazing this would be
totally done right and it's a beautiful
[Music]
on the lights course on how the rook on
a one does absolutely squat because the
king is shielded by its own pawns
against any kind of counter by that's
why yeah yeah you got nothing you got
squat rook h8 and and that's the h6 is
big play h6 has been played in our
Aronian is thinking I would assume he's
going to go H 5 H 5 is no we have rupee
8 on the board check ok first not h5 not
on King H 2
no none of the moves that we have been
we're just fine I can page 5 next move
you can play try the next move King to
f6 this is the position we have on the
board
rook to b8 rook to boy 8 and he has
captured the pawn takes a 4 and Livan is
playing way it's playing so fast I know
exactly what I'm doing
this is brilliant you've got you where I
want you kind of thing he's just played
rook b6 check I played king f7
anticipating that's what Maxine will do
and he has played King f7 and again I'm
with you a hundred percent I think you
play h5 hit it here ok and again we we
now know what the idea is which is to
bring the King through the
the Gateway hf5 now I got to ask you to
play like Maxine how do you stop white
from achieving what he wants that is a
good question yes sir understand that I
don't want to use the engine to not too
much because it's a very interesting
position I want to try to figure it out
myself as well exact but I think you
will have it will have to do something
with keeping the rock on now a - okay
tied to the Pallonji - whenever you go
g3 I'm going to reap recycle that the
rook on a tree I'm going to put it on a
tree back I want to play a a 4 or a 3 I
don't want to do any of that maybe a 5
if I could be an idea though I think I
want to keep your rook on the side of
the pond
ok rather than behind the pond so you
don't wage - I'm just going to start
waiting ok - King h2 King yourself King
is 7 try to figure this one out
ok King F so I'm going to continue
sitting now because your rook is I can't
I can't run
and lose my part on G - oh I'll play the
move g3 rook to a3 ok so now I have to
defend my partner and now again you'll
just wait and now I wait let's say T 7
so the same thing that if I go King f5
with the idea of king takes e5 I yeah
give up my f3 pawn which is something
I'd rather not do okay so you probably
want to play a 4 right so I'm assuming
you're gonna take will get this kind of
it kind of does I agree with you Jeff I
mean King do i v e5 is your stuff I mean
that king is a participant in the
Avalanche fit the pawns
put forward where you're just right
please ever to try - this is simply not
getting any sort of counterplay and
again David was mentioning at the game
of Miguel night are from Michael Babinec
and he was explaining that there was a
missing ePHI pawn but this g3 pomp this
now f4 pawn was back on g3 it's actually
even stronger on f4 than it was in that
game between five Bennigan's night earth
famous ending so this is actually
looking really good for LaVon just
getting that on the h5 and making a
gateway for his King this is the current
position Jennifer if I got this right
yeah I think so yeah it looks like we
see the borer there okay yes so this low
right now has a lot of time we're not
talking about time trouble anymore has
the 40 move mark and he needs to find
the exact defense he needs to be
extremely precise let's try to push up
on all the way to the look to to the
second round
so okay five okay six let's go a4 okay
cage because it seems that active of
just waiting and losing timing doesn't
work you have to create some sort of
active plate related to the pawn on e4
so a3 a3 g3 yes has to be played and
let's go rook e1 okay so here now a -
yeah yes yeah so the idea here is that
the moment my King steps across I have
to target yeah your palm yeah and you
need to have the pawn on a two because
otherwise I would go F 4 right in this
position in Section 5 yeah
here you're threatening the Queen yes
nobody even before instead of King at 5
I would go to move f4 yes no longer have
that move connect the pawns in the
center because I'm just going to take
and now you cannot recapture with any
piece because of check and then a
right your your your threat of promotion
is so strong he seems to be defending by
one move one tempo so and he's not
losing time he played a move a fight
immediately immediately a5 okay okay
it's always a good idea after it moved
like a five to get the room but behind
the pawn it wants because that stops any
options of moving the rook to the side
and we're gonna keep an eye on this game
before the short break and we're gonna
give you some more information about the
lohia foundation which brings I care to
third world countries and that's
actually one of the sponsors of the
limited chess class a wonderful
[Music]
I think many people don't know that
catcher blindness in Indonesia is number
two highest in the world this is no
longer a health problem by the social
problem
[Music]
what are your king or your beggar you
deserve equal quality I care
it all started because of dr. Ruth who
runs the taganga high care hospital in
in Nepal and I read about him I was
following his story and I was extremely
fortunate to meet him in Singapore I
think that's where a journey began how
many fingers am i holding up
elidio Nicola he inspired us to consider
looking at cataract as one of the
healthcare initiatives for our
foundation
[Music]
I often say we are changing lives
because all these people who come walk
into a camp who are blind and leave the
next day with high side I have
personally heard so many stories from
each camp where truly lives are changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here kiss you too much
my visa Herrera comma proceed how do you
feel very happy I'm very happy now maybe
my eyes or playoffs
oh very nice
[Music]
I'm so happy to say that in this
cataract camp there were more than 13
volunteers who flew in from different
parts of the world just by word of mouth
we were able to inspire even 13 people
[Music]
restoring eyesight is such such an
immediate effect they come back the next
day and they're able to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is life-changing experience you see
a person blind one today and tomorrow
the person can see me again
I mean how what more can you ask for but
what are the miracle cameras
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway or stir bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us
you guys know I can't play this right
st. Loup is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of the
London chest classic the last stop my
friends have for our finals as we see
here the top talent waltzing around I
just saw go in Joan yes but here we see
Levon Aronian seeing whether he can be
the only man to spill blood in the
classical portion so far here at the
Ranchester finals and will he do it well
yes what do you think
well Jennifer on our break that was
exactly what Christian and I were in
discussing we think so and it really
takes active play right Christian we
were looking at rook coming to a suit
because we felt that it's absolutely
imperative to require white to play the
move each immediate immediate active
play yeah you cannot lose a single tempo
King age to a a four or King age three
was our main line right we call it for
be how it went a 3 a 3 and now I had to
play g3 and I want to bring my king to
g4 but I don't want to lose my g2 part
and I think he did play them over ok -
by the way and our k1 another ok one and
then King g4 exactly and now a - this
was it was crucial that you get your
pawn to a 2 so that you're ready to move
your rook or work h1 for instance if
King f5 we have work age Ron King the
rook h1 a definite idea to trade you one
he wants to develop for a palm we were
always of this forget one Darius you to
get this one for this one but I think
your rook h1 is actually good enough -
the problem with Luke H 1 this is
exactly exactly what happened to Fabiano
in his first rapid game he forgot about
an intermediary cha right one okay seven
right that makes all the difference in
the world I'm hanging on to something
I'm not saying it's it's winning by any
means right now I think it might be
because after Luke age five king g6 I'm
actually threatening check
yeah that looks pretty passive so you
like work everyone better
yes yeah also I got the feeling that
with such an active King there's the
serious issues with this active King I
still think you're within our equality
range but Arthur ug5 potentially ruby g5
but then you you go f4 you have to deal
with the the connected pastor see it's
not easy especially from a practical
point of view no this is the way to go
not yeah this kid this active King you
know I'll get a pass on an epoch but
okay but definitely rook f1 changes the
complexion there our current position
King ish - he played and Maxime is is
pushing spot pay for okay they're
playing so quickly they really feel like
they've got to figure it out yes yes
they do who at this point like white
force a pre played that's what they
think so mean now they will have reached
our key position now in this moment I
can force it to be black smooth like
that but the the why would yeah but why
how would you do that I could like move
my my rook around okay you know and then
I go King f6 yeah I like something like
this Rhino six and then I have Voki knee
six and oh it's so much and it's the
same is the same position I have F 676
right sorry you think that at some point
you have to go for King f5 or there some
other way okay just a second so this is
our position we'll be looking at f4
earlier but now that now it's different
because we were trying to I think we
were playing it before you got a two and
rook a 180 right now of course if f4
unfortunately ours too we lose our
shield because after pawn takes that for
pawn takes that forward there's a few
ones I write and the lines that we were
looking at where black was not as
we pushing the up on that wasn't
possible
exactly that's interesting because I
think that the intuition was don't push
the pond so quickly because it boxes you
in at the end and the work is in a worse
spot on a1 but actually turns out that
it it seems like it's the best defense
because because of that could that
prevent that f4 idea and again it's the
most active way rightful for the
defender to push your bomb as quickly
it's an increase position it's a very
complete calculate calculation based
position and it seems like LaVon just
simply lost all his advantage in our
InDesign game by the way
g3 was played on display is already on
the board we are expecting King G for a2
and then the players will have reached
this key moment let's try to do this
exercise let's try to lose the tempo
with black so let's say instead of rook
to 8 - let's assume he would have played
the move root 2 a1 check I'm sorry which
moment after route to a6 after working
right here ok after work 26 to work to
a-1 let's see if it makes a difference
or not I just want to I just want to
understand whether rotating was
necessary I think a the game you NBL has
provoked the move g3 and I think that's
actually very important
a3 because this is where we get that
previa idea the King comes to f5 yeah
with the pod on g2 and I've got ideas of
rook shack and the ponies protected on
f3 that is the difference so that was
that was very very clever in the game
position for what mvl has done yeah and
we actually have the position where the
King on g4 and the pollinator ok
we've reached that position this is this
is the key moment Aronian is thinking
how to make any progress there is
absolutely no other way [ __ ] a5
you're right ok so let's assume king of
5 let's assume we left one and he went
for it
alive yeah and let's let look let's give
a check
let's give a check King Jay King to g8
now do i whistle on g8 that this would
be wonderful to go King to g6 and
threaten checkmate
but rook takes and I'd get checkmated
yeah yeah so rook check here rook takes
and it's like g7 would have worked would
have been okay better but yeah ather
okay well you can also go a one yes a
one stops mate oops and wins the game
we're looking at a lot of lot of lines
that would please the Frenchman great
analysis yeah
so we're expecting after King GA
triptychs right there look they say I
think is the only movie in the position
or okay check but that doesn't really
make a difference we get three we get
one and that's expected I gotta say you
did play that move with a bit of a lon
like I had mentioned earlier if he does
manage to save us how how beautiful it
is it's a different type of feeling kind
of more like finishing a tough workout
yeah yes and definitely you know
sometimes you just gotta tip your hat
but here we we feel that LaVon as though
is going to be very upset with himself
he has about that rook a
that was all the difference in the world
black got an active rook and he should
not he needs to be upset about
Ruka rooks it - instead of rook e1 what
he could have played he needs to be
upset about h6 yesterday what he could
have played a lot of could have in in in
this instance and LaVon is not finishing
his opponents off there is a big problem
and it seems
be plaguing him all throughout the year
some will have to wait and see whether
his intuition is going to speed up and
he's just simply not going to be allowed
to overthink these decisions and maybe
that's actually going to help him in the
rapid and Blitzstein controls because
his preparation is top-notch that is
clear he trained he trained diligently
for for this match I don't think he has
only one idea in store I think he
prepared a lot of ideas that he will
show during the rapid and Blitzstein
controls but he has to get over the
slump of not finishing the game yeah
well again today Jena an hour extra on
the clock really really nice position
and here's our schedule well we've got
wrapping him blitz tomorrow that's gonna
start at 2 p.m. in London that's a day
I'm here in st. Louis we actually start
at 7:50 local time in st. Louis 8:50 and
the East Coast followed by a rest day on
Friday and then we have our finals as we
know we're going to have one American
and one of these men who are currently
battling now to review the format's for
the other types of chats well rapids
gonna be game 25 with a 10 second delay
so that'll be 4 points at stake for each
game and then we move on to blitz five
minutes with the three second delay so
not the fastest of limits games which
you know potentially cuts into the
potential edge of maxime and he caro in
these formats but still pretty fast and
gosh that's gonna be a treat so much
chess on the third day of each of these
mini matches exactly and 14 points up
for grabs at 8 on the on the rapid 12
and 16 it should be right yeah Wow
anywhere the money is if after that we
we still have a tie we go with high
breaks with the time control is going to
be even lower and then if the tie breaks
if the Blitz tie breaks are going to be
equal then we go into the Armageddon and
the only match that I can remember going
into the Armageddon between
top layers was the one between MVL and
Aronian last year in the 2017 World Cup
in which they went to Armageddon and
actually there was a topsy-turvy man
topsy-turvy game because I think what
the decide that had to win could have
won in the end and instead of that he he
allowed the counter play he made a
drawing and black one that than that
match which was Aronian and qualified to
the canvas spot and the rest is history
but this these guys have some history
between each other and I think we're
going to see a very very complex very
long match between these two between
this together yeah well I still remember
watching these two players playing in
that semi-final in the World Cup and as
you said it was Levon who qualified
which secured his candidacy into Berlin
as well he want the finals against thing
there in and that was big big big prize
money so when these two guys get
together there's a lot at stake
absolutely and we do have by the way
rook takes a two there was the here
LaVon was thinking whether or not he
should first toss in a cheque or not he
decided that his best option was rook
takes a two we can expect rook takes a
three check and I'm assuming you don't
like King g4 and offer a draw but you
play King takes e5 and do you sorry do
you what do you play King e5 or do you
just go kingi for enough for a draw I go
can you fly
King e5 and then I'm probably got four
ollie
anyway yeah I know I read I think that
after rook takes you know I I don't know
I mean just just to suggest that I could
go rook h2 and King f4 and well after
Rick g5 check I think it's going to be a
easy draw no but he look at him he knows
it he knows he knows he's the other one
he's let his prey escape hard to win a
chess game in London
that's going on John I mean I I remember
ourselves being here at the Sinfield cup
and watching a certain shall we call him
Bobby on a car you wanna have a streak
of seven consecutive wins it's
incredible I mean that wasn't such an
outstanding result but at any one D 14
Wow I mean even in four years later you
wonder if it's as likely now as players
training with stronger computers and
having even better defensive and opening
ideas right I don't know has obviously
that even at that time that wasn't a
massive anomaly to consoie liar but it
would be even rarer now right what do
you think Christian would that would
that result be even less likely now
which one well Fabiano for example I'll
give you another interesting stat he
didn't lose a single classical game
since Ruth Stamm chasm Journal became
his coach in London so he's traveling
with him to London since 2015 he hasn't
lost a single game in classical chess
and I don't think he lost a lot of rapid
games either until the match against
Magnus Carlsen in which he lost three
rapid games but yeah I think it's it's
very difficult we know a game nowadays
especially between these guys and it
shows well another quick contrast for a
second 2018 we had an extraordinary
event here in st. Louis
the u.s. championship and Fabiano had a
phenomenal US Championship gaining
rating points I think he was +5 was
Fabiana but then there was a guy his
name was Sam Shanklin Shankman decided
to go plus six and become the new US
Champion and it was just an amazing US
Championships was yeah victories galore
I want to say that was extraordinary in
Fabiano's games are also so dazzling
right I think even Magnus had a little
quick for it afterwards where he said
well don't worry five it's been a while
since I've won the Norwegian
championship okay
and by the way we do have this king
takes e5 variation on the board but no
rook h2 it was a simple rookie 7 check
is is LaVon pudding is trusted and this
has one hour and 46 minutes on the clock
King g8 did he lose his patience in this
game at critical moments I mean he had
so much time to think it out did LaVon
LaVon yeah yeah he has so much time left
on the clock I mean we could be sitting
here for another three hours just to
take it to our boss boy oh boy
and he has just played King d6 so he's
putting all of his eggs behind this
eform basket was that a good decision
Christian you can for example check it's
definitely the practical decision yeah
you can check on d3 then I'm going to go
King to e7 or 6 rookie you go okay 4 and
you can still not push the pawns yet so
I can't even go g6 in this situation g6
I think it should be enough and then
black will capture this pawn and he will
start pushing and eventually everything
will come up once my King gets active I
don't think I would have any sort of
problems defending this one so I want to
play king g6 after Chuck so King d6
obviously white is hoping that black
will be seduced by this part on the h5
and just allow this epon to go out the
board when suddenly you get a situation
where it's like whoops it's too late the
pawn on the e pawn it's a girl that's
game over exactly so that was why we
were thinking that after King d6 do not
dilly-dally and take this pawn but just
know g6 first immediately create a
passport
g6 you know I think that you guys when
you said it's a girl like I got a thank
you because I've been trying to think of
a name for that a configuration where
you have like a pawn on e7 and I work on
a a yes that's a little more colorful
like that cuz once that's a really
important and game configuration and
exact but it doesn't have a name like
the Philidor the Lucena is nice yeah so
when I teach people I'm trying to just
say yeah remember that but what's that
and now I'm thinking the Midwife right
it did not deliver yes yeah okay we
we're making chess history well we're at
our creative best of these moments right
that's right root these three as well
sorry what out of g6 yeah I like the
rules let's see if that no no King g6 I
want breaking g6 oh you want to play the
support that pawn so whenever you go
rookie three I go e five I see
oh if he wants to play rookie three I
don't think you do but right shall we
say greedy
maybe I mean that because oh yeah nine
your pawn isn't that frightening or
maybe it is excuse me I I meant to take
this pawn of course
come on sorry my mouse is slipping there
we go
all right so all right so the idea is of
course to come back and come back around
let's try to go route through it first
okay so that horses my king Oh your way
yeah away from the has to go to d6 do I
want to go King the six or do I just
want to put her behind the pawn so root
2 a1 for example all right
a3 is fine okay okay three is fine as
well oh I don't know it was it would
help my might my mouse okay at least for
the moment that I'll come down and you
couldn't get behind the part rookie
dream yeah but now you haven't not my
King has can come back I seem to be a
little bit slow right maybe my king can
come back and I'll be in time to block
it block the power yeah yeah no it seems
like it seems that if I don't actually
get the Queen that pawn immediately yeah
you get a configuration which is
allowing you to defend exactly so with
the King on the e-file you're safe
you're safe being greedy I'm safe being
greedy but he played which makes the
most sense to be honest it's the most
practical chance after king d6 he did
not play rook d3 media Brigade check
from Livan really literally as if it was
a blitz man yeah wow he's ready
well he has
we say two hours all right 47 minutes
yes plenty of time to think it through
but there's not much thing through right
now okay yeah just sorry I know he
played we'll check and I guess he's
about to offer a draw that had he played
a fight what was the idea seven rotate
seven check on the board by the way Gino
7r okay seven what what about just
checking the weather soon
yeah there are ok 8 king at seven all
explained right
okay okay a David Sedgwick of the grand
Chester had written me earlier to
clarify that it's only in completely
dead drawn and games that they're able
to have a draw by by decoration because
they don't want to put the arbiter in
the awkward position exactly and here we
have it LaVon and maximize our graph
Bravo on the defense and VL he held his
own today
in the position that looked so
terrifying right now that was well done
LaVon of course a little bit
disappointed as he's very disappointed
great opportunities in both games but
especially in this one I think so too
not to criticize because it's tough it's
tough
it was exactly here however we've got to
give great credit to fvl to come up with
night before night a to it's not like
the most intuitive mood but it was right
here that this move rook anyone and
there you have it and yes indeed we got
the semifinals all the classic games are
in the books and they've all been drawn
for games here in the semi-finals all
drawn but I can tell you one thing edge
we're not gonna see 12 draws tomorrow no
we're not we're gonna see a lot of
action in the rapid and the blitz and
yeah we're gonna see a lot of decisive
games I just wanted to say here on my
board this is where we were all
thumping the table for the move rook c2
and we feel that this was the key moment
of the whole game and Christian if you
could explain why absolutely that was
the whole difference I'm dashing Aronian
for the fact that he didn't find Luke C
- I'm a little bit disappointed that he
didn't spend more time in trying to
decipher this position right as you do
generally when you're in good shape you
know you try to get to the bottom of it
you try to understand the truth in the
position he wasn't patient enough and
that's why I'm a little bit disappointed
I'm a little bit upset at him and I
think he's upset at himself as well
because he had the time he had the time
that's the thing so much money have an
hour in 30 minutes maybe an hour in 20
minutes at this point in the game and he
could have fun I mean he's a quality
player he's one of the top guys out
there you will be able to find rook c2
if you give it some thought I feel he
just like rushed when four okay one
understood that he has a pawn up and he
has good chances of converting but you
need more precision to win games at this
level agreed all around and if I could
also be a little critical at this moment
myself I also thought that again when
you think about the chess clock and how
much time he had I thought Knight c5 was
also a very very impatient move it's not
like black has any really great threats
and I thought that I like to move very
much before I thought that that was the
most incisive but because of the clock
situation I also said I like h4 and
saying hey how you like your position
you know ahead and play absolutely
return what are you gonna do and just
put a little bit more pressure on my
opponent put my palm on h5 played b4
prior to putting the knight on c5 and
then I mean again this was a really this
is an incredible idea at night before
and b6 yeah I mean m b6 and just going
into
this on down ending and nvl just he
found a little window and he crawled his
way through it to a draw and we have
Alejandra with LaVon in London
thank you guys I'm here with Levon
Aronian pressing again in the classical
game but not enough tell us a little bit
about what happened it's kind of a
innocent looking wine but it can play it
sometimes had the surprise d4 seem like
your opponent wasn't ready for it yeah
yeah and well he played precisely and
then the position is generally close to
equality in this in the same game yeah
but visually it's better for white right
the double points got a bad impression
yeah so got something going on right
yeah even one apart at some point yeah
yeah and then well I think he miss
played it somehow and then here well I
mean I have all kinds of moves I can
play before but I thought 95 h4 is you
know very tempting very direct yeah yeah
I actually missed this night before idea
not that it's a great idea but if at
least he gets he gets to jump around all
of it and here I thought this should be
very close to be winning that's what I
heard we're actually wondering if you
missed Christian was very critical if
you remove rook a1 supposed to move rook
C - oh my god
yeah that's embarrassing how
embarrassing is this not this hero
of course we both missed it yeah the
idea obviously that route C to explain
to the audience taking B 3 and unlike
the game the replacement actually gets
in the c5 time Wow
yeah and then should be winning
strange somehow you think that you have
to go and take the knife but it's not
going anywhere but here it also should
be winning somehow I think I had many
options from c3 I thought it's a good
option and something like h5 or King ish
- because before is always runs to the
Roxy yeah no no no not here check and
then I can always play which will be
weird at some point either harassing the
phones it feels like you've been
revising right after - yeah it feels
like you've been pressing twice but
accuracies not being very strong here
letting very inaccurate thing in my
place no somehow I thought that I have
all the Tempe in the world but of course
yeah it's weird where it's somehow
summation well you're going into the
rapid and blitz now tied with Maxie
michela graph I feel a little bit of
your frustration here coming out of the
game but one day to recover and good
luck in the rapid of blitz
thank you very much well thank you the
one and let's go back to the studio s
will soon have Mike Selig Roth thank you
look forward to MDL interview as well
boy big miss there and the first thing
when rook c2 was suggested to LaVon is
like he just bang hit himself upside his
head how could I miss that much he had
all the time in the world to think about
it I guess this is one of those moves
that escapes their vision because it
seems like you need to take the night I
mean that's not bad
these are this is why computer engines
are so powerful but the thing is these
top players are so used to working with
computers that if he had thought a
little longer he would have seen that of
course yeah yeah not that not that uh
the palm were keys in Kappa blanka's
wouldn't have either
no I'm sure they would have also and it
was just like one of those things where
he rushed he rushed her to several times
in this game it was almost like he was
impatient to win Christian no absolutely
and it's an easy position
it's very easy to miss this type of
ideas when there's a lot more pieces on
the board but there's like two pieces on
the board a couple of rooks and a knight
I mean take your time find the move rook
c2e you will find it I guarantee you as
a 28 as a 27 as a 2600 I think you will
find those type of moves at least is
going to become one of your candidate
moves right and then you're going to be
able to develop and understand what you
have to do later but you have to find it
anyway let's go back to London because
we have Alejandra with MDL thanks
Christian we're here with my team
Vaishali graph mixing seems like you've
suffered twice in the classical guys but
you made it through
yeah today I I couldn't remember this
line because I've rechecked a bit of
everything but this is different what I
shoot up I mean it's it's my fault and
so you were trying to remember your
preparation or you have it Shakti for I
probably checked but I couldn't remember
so I just started a new like I realized
that magtec's deforms to dangerous after
a while and I'm not sure I should have
gone for decent game because yeah after
night xt4 I realized that maybe I should
play Bishop Seco but yeah but I wasn't
sure it's a bit dangerous and yeah after
Bishop d2 and I assumed find a way there
but then I missed its very nice idea
absolutely should be screaming which is
not that difficult to find that eh I'm
definitely suffering and for a while it
looks like
I mean after night this film of 23 I
thought like I'm probably close to two
lost but I am managed to keep on
fighting and I found this idea was night
before and physics which probably should
be lost but yeah I saw this focusing on
more 28 yes you did sir Exeter
yeah it probably wins but I'm
it's it's probably more precise but I
still managed to get my hug to d1 so I
thought yeah after King 66 bb3 okay I
mean they're sticking it to but yeah at
least I have some checks I do I do
manage to to get my work but of course
it was better than the game and students
again I sorted should be lost but it was
I mean I couldn't find a definitive I
hoped I would let him find it I'll try
to find it myself but we're not for a
while also couldn't find a direct win
for white there in that position I mean
you could definitely cost more and it
was a particular position where you
think I mean I Singh Kham d8 was this
one right there right yeah it wasn't
over stable c3 yeah something exists I
mean I'm not sure it's it's probably
overdue is enjoying margin I thought
about this and I don't know maybe it
just maybe like try to instead of King
edge or maybe a huge three doesn't
matter like try to get this position I
don't know how exactly like kingi sphere
yeah which position area hey I'm trying
to get the same position as in the game
exist position but with the pond on g2
okay yeah yeah we didn't see actually a
way to make yeah because I might have
cancer
yes I thought so but then maybe you won
and my king gets to a fate instead of g8
and I so writes it slightly more
dangerous but obviously you're going it
to the faster time controls and it seems
like today you spend a lot of time with
the opening trying to get out of trouble
you still kind of got into trouble
anything you need to change before we
get into tomorrow what am i preparation
I guess but it's on me it's definitely
on me and well I'm hoping to to find
some time tonight too
we check some of these signs I'm sure
you have a long night ahead of you six
games tomorrow
good luck Messina thanks for joining us
here thank you and we go back to the
studio with the guys in st. Louis Thank
You alejandro and there we have it in
the semi-finals Jennifer all tied up
that's right and we're gonna be coming
back tomorrow to break those ties as we
have a blitz and rapid but let's go to a
Christian gorilla for his final thoughts
on today's action oh absolutely we we
have some amazing chess extraordinary
preparation especially from Aronian
Hikaru I cannot blame him to be honest I
would probably have done the same thing
try to neutralize blacks ideas any sort
of ideas make a draw go into my
strengths which is the rapid and the
blades time controls and take it from
there I think this is the most practical
choice by he Carwin he took a page from
Magnus Carlsen so ideas Aronian needs to
understand what he's doing wrong I think
he does and he needs to change that he
needs to play a bit more intuitively and
he needs to find those critical moments
and spend more time in those critical
moments I'm sure he knows that he will
have to get out of this slump and do
better next time
and VL is doing quite well the problem
is his repertoire is a little bit static
and he's an easy target for aronia he's
going to be the story tomorrow will he
be able to change something overnight
will he go with the same weapons in the
battle and will Aronian come up with
some new ideas it's going to be a fun
day tomorrow and I'm looking forward to
call all the action with you guys but
let's go to London and hear what
Alejandro's final thoughts are now I
have to agree with you Christian that is
definitely going to be the story in that
match tomorrow can I run and keep coming
up with the surprises I Maxine that's
been against the ropes twice in a row
can he turn that script around very
exciting games as you said Christian
what he karma has done against Fabi kind
of expected he wants to save us energy
for tomorrow what's the safest for
prices in the opening for tomorrow it's
going to be very exciting all tied up
going into the rapid and blitz well
we'll be here tomorrow to call all the
action
thank you ollie Andrew
Jim well I can't wait yes as we've seen
so many drawls in London the idea that
these rabbit and blitz are really going
to show us so much excitement I think
that Bobby's gonna do great in the rapid
but Nakamura is gonna really be pressing
in the Blitz
so that match is in my mind really tough
to call and then the other match of
course anything can happen but a similar
story LaVon getting the edge in the
rapid and yellow in the blitz so much to
watch and it's all gonna go down
tomorrow at 2 p.m. in the London which
is 8 a.m. here in st. Louis right we'll
be here to call all the action thank you
so much for sharing your day with us and
be sure to join us tomorrow as well
thank you and good bye
[Music]